Musik
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Auf geht's.
Aber ein bisschen was entspannenderes an.
Ich mach es leiser.
So, Chat.
Und, wie war die Nacht bei euch?
Ganz schön warm, ne?
Ja.
Aber das ging.
Ich habe eine Klimaanlage.
Dementsprechend ging das.
Ganz gut.
wobei ich die klimaanlage nachts eigentlich so gut wie nicht an habe ich mache die abends an
was ist wie sie runterkühlt und dann mache ich die irgendwie so 12 mal noch nachts an
meistens wenn ich aufs klo muss und merke wie warm es ist dann mache ich noch mal kurz an
und macht wieder wieder aus nach zehn minuten aber so jeden fall zu warm
Ist auf jeden Fall deutlich zu warm.
Aber, kannst nichts machen.
Da müssen wir durch, Chat.
Du kannst dir keine einbauen lassen, oder?
Also viele Leute, die halt eine Wohnung gemietet haben, geht halt leider nicht, weil der Vermieter keinen Bock drauf hat.
Ich bin eh der Meinung, wir sollten in Deutschland, ich meine gerade mal im Hinblick auf wie sich das die nächsten Jahre entwickeln wird oder Jahrzehnte entwickeln wird, es wird ja immer wärmer, wir sollten einfach überall Klimaanlagen einbauen.
Aufhalten werden wir das eh nicht mehr
Können sie es vielleicht ein bisschen eindämmen
Aber aufhalten werden wir das Ganze nicht mehr
Sie sollten einfach überall Klimaanlagen einbauen
Muss ich mal überlegen, es gibt Krankenhäuser ohne Klimaanlagen
Was machen denn die Leute?
Sollen die jetzt bei 35 Grad
Sich erholen oder was?
Kostengründe?
So teuer war das nicht
Ich kann jetzt natürlich nicht für aktuelle Sachen sprechen
Aber ich glaube ich habe knapp über 2000 Euro bezahlt
Aber es ist ja schon ein paar Jahre her
mittlerweile kostet wahrscheinlich 8000 euro oder so weil alles super teuer
geworden ist denn du rockstank schön für den sub
hock subskript ja so richtig so ja ja bisschen über 2k das ganze gekostet das
ging das ging voll klar mit der klimaanlage
ich habe halt außen an der wand dieses dieses das außen teil und innen habe ich
in zwei Räumen
halt so ein
Innengerät
davon, die halt alles zu diesem
Gerät außen gehen.
Und ich glaube, man kann da theoretisch bis zu
fünf, wenn ich das richtig gelesen
habe damals, man kann da glaube ich
bis zu fünf
Innengeräte an diesem Außending
anschließen. Ob man
jetzt alle fünf auf volle Pulle laufen lassen kann,
ob das Ding packt, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber brauchst du ja auch nicht.
Und ich bin tatsächlich schon am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht irgendwie auch mein Wohnzimmer noch so ein Innengerät bauen lassen soll.
Das Ding ist nur, du musst quasi einmal durch mein Arbeitszimmer durch mit irgendeinem Rohr, dass dann das Außengerät drankommt, weil das ist quasi komplett an der entgegengesetzten Wand.
Also wahrscheinlich werde ich es lassen.
Außerdem ist es wahrscheinlich schweineteuer mittlerweile
Weil alles ultra teuer geworden ist
Hab ich euch schon erzählt?
Ich hatte diese Woche
Ein Teambuilding Event
Montagabend bis Mittwochnachmittag
Und das war so
Das war in einem Hotel
Aber das war halt so ein bisschen auf schicker gemacht
Das war kein Sterne-Restaurant oder sowas.
Wisst ihr, was da die Currywurst gekostet hat?
Der habe ich euch schon erzählt, ne?
Das habe ich euch schon erzählt.
Die Currywurst.
Currywurst mit Pommes frites.
19 Euro.
Aber die Firma hat es ja bezahlt.
Also mir war das egal.
Ich habe auch keine Currywurst gefuttert.
Aber 19 Euro ist schon echt ordentlich, ne?
Sportlich.
Okay, es gab zwei Currywürste
Es war nicht nur eine Currywürste
Es waren zwei Currywürste
Das waren jetzt aber nicht die größten
Die fettesten Currywürste
Also, sag mal so, du kommst vielleicht auf eineinhalb ordentliche Currywürste
Aber trotzdem
19 Euro ist echt ordentlich
Aber wie gesagt, ich musste es nicht bezahlen
Aber das, was ich gefordert habe
War auch brutal teuer
Ich habe
Was habe ich gegessen? Vorspeise
So eine Mozzarella
Tomaten-Mischmasch-Zeug.
Ups. Hätte ich vielleicht warten
sollen, hier mit umstöpseln.
Das hat 17 Euro gekostet.
Dann
ein bisschen Flammkuchen. Das hat irgendwie, glaube ich,
10 Euro gekostet.
Oder irgendwie sowas. Keine Ahnung. Weiß ich mal genau.
Bisschen Rindfleisch als Hauptgericht.
Das hat 33 Euro. Das war
wirklich nicht viel, ja.
33 Euro gekostet.
Und dann habe ich noch...
Ich meine, wie gesagt, ich muss es nicht bezahlen. Privat wäre ich
da im Leben auch nicht hingegangen.
Dann habe ich mir noch ein Stück Apfeltorte und Schokoladenkuchen mit Sahne bestellt
Das hat irgendwie auch jeweils 7 Euro oder sowas nochmal gekostet
Also ja, ich habe da quasi
Allein am ersten Tag habe ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 80 Euro oder so verfressen
Und ich habe nichts getrunken, ne?
Also kein Wein oder irgendwie sowas
Ich trinke ja so gut wie kein Alkohol
Ich trinke vielleicht mal an Weihnachten oder Silvester was
Aber ansonsten so gut wie nie was
und
ich, also ich hab an dem Abend
eigentlich nur Wasser und
ich glaub einen Eistee hab ich noch getrunken, ja.
Max, hast du auch, dass du
morgens total früh wach wirst?
Nee.
Hab ich nicht, aber
ich nehm ja auch abends meistens noch
eine halbe Tablette,
was ein bisschen müde macht.
Aber ich hab auch schon ein paar Tage jetzt mal getestet,
Da habe ich nur eine Vierteltablette genommen.
Manche Tage habe ich sogar schon mal getestet, komplett ohne.
Das geht eigentlich.
Das geht.
Aber es kann ja durchaus sein, weil das macht ja munter.
Achso, du meinst, du hast es dann schon einen Tag nicht mehr genommen.
Ja.
Ne, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Es muss auch nicht zwangsläufig daran liegen, ganz ehrlich.
Ich glaube man...
Okay, ne.
Ich glaube auch, man schreibt viele Sachen da den Medikamenten zu, ohne dass es wirklich der Auslöser ist.
Weil es hat ja einen Grund, warum man das nimmt.
Und wahrscheinlich trägt das auch oftmals dazu bei, gerade mit schlechter Schlaf.
Träumst du, ja, das habe ich auch.
Ich träume teilweise super wirres Zeug.
Ich habe letztens geträumt, das ist total wirr.
Also, muss sagen, also für alle, nur so ein bisschen ausholen, ja.
Ich nehme aktuell Pillen hier für die Psyche.
Und die haben als eine Nebenwirkung, die wohl recht bekannt ist, glaube ich, steht auf dem Beipackzettel, abnormale Träume oder irgendwie sowas.
Und alter Leute, ich träume, also ich habe jetzt nicht wirklich Albträume oder so.
Ich träume teilweise den übelsten Scheiß.
Ich träume wirklich den übelsten Scheiß.
Ich habe letztens geträumt, dass mich der Sänger von Rammstein, keine Ahnung, ey, hast du keine Ahnung, warum, ja?
Der Sänger von Rammstein hat mich irgendwo runtergeworfen.
WTF, keine Ahnung, warum runtergeworfen und warum der Sänger von Rammstein, ich weiß es nicht, ja?
Keine Ahnung.
Also ich träume total wirres Zeug.
Ja, siehste, das ist, das ist total, ähm, individuell, was man da hat.
Aber es ist nicht schlimm. Also ich träume jetzt nichts Schlimmes.
Und jetzt nicht übermäßig schlimmes Zeug.
Ich träume halt abgedrehtes Zeug und ich kann mich morgens mehr dran erinnern.
Nee, aber dass ich morgens total früh wach werde, habe ich nicht.
Was ist denn bei dir total früh wach?
Was wollte ich jetzt? Ich wollte doch eigentlich irgendwas vom Essen erzählen.
Genau, und die Leute haben ja teilweise
Dann sich irgendwie zig
Dinger Wein bestellt und sowas
In dem Restaurant
Wir haben bestimmt bei diesem Teambuilding-Event
Im mittleren vierstelligen Betrag nur verfressen
Musst du mal alles aufschreiben?
Nee
Ich bin froh, dass ich das vergesse
Das ist alles viel zu wirr
Froh, dass ich das meiste davon nicht mehr weiß
Hast du eigentlich irgendwann vor, die Tabletten abzusetzen?
Ja, ja, klar
Ja klar, ein bisschen
Also je nachdem, du hast ja auch gestern geschrieben
Dass du sehr hohe Dosis genommen hast
Aber klar, ich mein
Das hat ja eine Wirkung
Und hat dementsprechend auch dämpfende Wirkung
Auf alles andere
Und gerade wenn man sich da wirklich sehr viel reinschmeißt
Ich mein, du hast ja 150 Milligramm genommen, hast du gestern geschrieben
Das ist das Doppelte von dem, was ich nehme
Und
Natürlich dämpft das nicht nur die Sachen
Die man nicht haben will
Sondern vielleicht auch die Sachen die man haben will
Ne
Will ich nicht
Ping Pepo Fett
Ja vielleicht
Moin Umut
Auch wieder am Start
Hock.
3 Uhr im Bett.
Ja gut, da hast du ja nur knapp 5 Stunden gepennt.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig.
Aber das kann durchaus sein, wenn du normal...
Also das muss jetzt wirklich nicht an den Pillen liegen.
Wenn du normal auch immer so um 8.30 Uhr aufstehst,
dann bist du einfach dran gewöhnt.
Also man muss da ein bisschen gucken,
dass man es nicht zu sehr den Pillen zuschreibt.
Es ist halt manchmal auch einfach natürliche Schwankung.
Vielleicht ein bisschen Pillen, ja, wenn man denkt, 100% die Pillen sind dafür verantwortlich, sind sie vielleicht in Wirklichkeit nur ein bisschen.
Also ich habe auch nicht lange gepennt letztens.
Ich war in, ich war ja vor ein paar Wochen in Hannover beim Iron Maiden Konzert.
Und da sind wir am gleichen Tag hingefahren nach Hannover und wieder zurück.
und da war ich auch um 3.45 Uhr
erst im Bett
und ich bin ganz normal aufgewacht
irgendwann um 8
oder 8.30 Uhr oder sowas
und
ich hab mich dann extra später
nochmal hingelegt und noch 2 Stunden gepennt
Aber mach dir nicht so viele Gedanken.
Solange du abends einpennen kannst und so, ist das alles okay.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich habe vor, das schon mal wieder abzusetzen.
Ich will es jetzt nicht mein restliches Leben lang unbedingt nehmen.
Aber ich werde das erstmal weiternehmen, weil die Empfehlung ist ja auch, man soll das quasi...
Wenn alles wieder gut ist, soll man es trotzdem mindestens sechs Monate noch weiternehmen.
Gehst du auf Rammstein-Konzerte? Nö.
Also das nächste, wo ich wahrscheinlich hingehe, ist...
Wie heißt das? Lorelei?
Bühne?
Frei, frei, Freilicht?
Frei, Freilicht?
Bühne?
Mir noch ein paar Opas angucken.
Hier gehe ich wahrscheinlich als nächstes hin.
Ja, gut.
Da hast du schon irgendwo recht.
Natürlich, ne?
Wenn es nach denen geht,
solltest du so viel von den Pillen,
wie irgendwie geht,
und so lang, wie irgendwie geht, nehmen,
weil die halt Geld verdienen wollen.
Ich...
Ich frag mich eh,
Das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen viel philosophiert oder so, aber ich frage mich ja eh, welche Anreize haben denn eigentlich Pharmaunternehmen, Tabletten herzustellen, die Leute heilen?
Am besten für die wäre es doch eigentlich, so wie bei Aids-Medikamenten oder sowas, dass die Pillen teuer sind, dass du die Pillen nehmen musst, weil du sonst stirbst und dass du die Pillen ein Leben lang nehmen musst.
Das ist doch eigentlich das, wovon Pharma-Stonks träumt, oder?
So viel wie geht, du musst sie nehmen und so lang wie möglich.
Also das ist doch für die Pharma-Stonks das Beste.
Das heißt, wenn die eine Auswahl haben,
wenn die eine Auswahl haben,
so Pillen, die irgendwas heilen,
versus Pillen,
die einfach nur
dich so alt werden lassen,
wie irgendwie normal
und du die ganzes Leben nehmen musst,
sind die doch eher dafür, oder?
Die Pillen machen... Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich rede jetzt ja nicht von den Pillen, die wir hier nehmen, sondern es gibt ja durchaus Pillen, so Antibiotika-Pillen zum Beispiel.
Die heilen dich ja.
Also, gibt ja schon Pillen, die dich gesund machen.
Bei uns, bei unseren Pillen, die wir hier nehmen, ist es eher so, dass du quasi neue Wege quasi im Gehirn bilden kannst
Das unterstützt dein Gehirn dabei zu heilen im Endeffekt, ja
Dass du neue Wege im Hirn bilden kannst und sowas
Das stimmt, die Pillen heilen dich an sich nicht, aber es gibt durchaus Pillen, die tatsächlich dafür sorgen, dass du wieder gesund wirst
Ja, also das ist das nächste, wo ich wahrscheinlich hingehe
Die sind ja auch mittlerweile schon
70 plus oder irgendwie sowas
Das ist auch alte Säcke
Was für Pillen nehmen wir?
Ich meine mit wir
Den Bravo Mike und den
690 Dude
Was ihr nehmt, weiß ich nicht
Aber die zwei nehmen das gleiche wie ich.
Und wir haben gestern im Chat gelernt, es gibt noch viel mehr den gleichen Kram, den will ich.
So, also das ist das nächste, was ich mir hier wahrscheinlich geben werde.
Und wo ich auch übelst drauf Bock habe, da steht leider noch nicht fest, wann das Event ist.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin so ein alter Power-Metal-Hörer.
Es gibt irgendwann Ende des Jahres noch.
in Frankfurt.
Bamamaixa, genau.
Es gibt irgendwann Ende des Frankfurts noch.
Äh...
Frankfurt, das da.
Das würde ich mir auch gerne hier.
Am 30. Oktober.
Also das sind wahrscheinlich die nächsten zwei Sachen, wo ich hingehe.
Einmal Judas Priest.
Hier Lorelei-Bühne.
Mal gucken, wie ich da hinkomme.
Und dann hier Rhapsody.
Beziehungsweise eines der 3000 verschiedenen Rhapsody-Projekte, die es gibt.
Das ist für die alten Power-Metaller.
Beste.
Hast du Ohrstöpsel oder hast du Tinnitus?
Ich habe immer Ohrstöpsel dabei.
Ich brauche die aber selten.
Aber ich habe immer Ohrstöpsel dabei,
falls das teilweise...
Also, ich habe es schon mal überlebt,
dass das übelst übersteuert war.
Und das hat dir echt die Ohren kaputt gemacht.
Aber in den letzten...
Also, bei den letzten Konzerten
habe ich keine Ohrstöpsel gebraucht.
Ganz ehrlich, es sollte auch so sein,
dass du keine Ohrstöpsel brauchst.
Ansonsten haben die irgendwie gefailt, ja
Lieber Sitzplatz oder in der Masse drin?
Ja, kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, wo das ist
Also das letzte, also in Hannover, das war ein Sitzplatz, das war ja ein Fußballstadion
Da gibt es halt an der Seite nur Sitzplätze.
Aber man hat die meiste Zeit gestanden.
Und ansonsten, ich gucke immer was.
Also, das ist halt das Ding.
Ich buche ungern Sachen wie das hier.
Guck mal, das will ich noch nicht buchen, weil es gibt hier halt noch keine.
Veranstaltungsort ist noch nicht bekannt gegeben.
Ich gucke mir halt immer gern an, wo das ist.
So, was das für einen Eindruck macht.
ansonsten muss ich nicht unbedingt vorne im pulk stehen weil ihr wisst ich bin
nur 174 und na ja da sieht man nicht unbedingt so so so tolle was ja übrigens
eins wollte ich dir noch sagen hier leidensgenosse hier mit den pillen 1 1
wollte ich dir noch sagen es kann auch durchaus sein weil du gerade gesagt dass
mit dem Frühaufwachen, das kann auch dadurch sein,
dass du schon damit rechnest, früh aufzuwachen
und dich quasi permanent selbst kontrollierst.
So nach dem Motto, bin ich schon wach, bin ich schon wach,
bin ich schon wach, kann ich wieder einschlafen.
Und durch dieses Ultra-Selbstkontrollieren
führst du quasi selbst das herbei, was du eigentlich nicht willst.
Ja, die Probleme hatte ich auch schon.
Wenn du verstehst, was ich meine.
Deswegen ist am besten, bei diesen ganzen Erkrankungen
zu versuchen, irgendwie zu sagen,
scheiß drauf.
Also irgendwie im Kopf so dieses Mindset zu kriegen,
ey, und selbst wenn es so ist,
dann ist es so, scheiß drauf, ja.
Es bringt mich nicht um, scheiß drauf.
Also das hilft bei mir ganz gut.
Wenn ich mir über
irgendwelche Sachen, ihr wisst ja,
ich habe ja das Problem, ich mache mir ultra
Gedanken über irgendwelche Krankheiten, die ich haben könnte.
Und ich meine,
ich wurde das letzte Jahr über so oft
untersucht und ich bin in Top-Verfassung,
ja.
Und...
Ja, aber vielleicht hast du den Zettel mit den Nebenwirkungen gelesen und sowas.
Also, aber gerade am Anfang bei den Pillen ist das ja auch normal.
Und da war das vielleicht am Anfang von den Pillen.
Und seitdem achtest du besonders drauf.
Das ist teilweise sehr subtil, was das Hirn da so treibt, ja.
Ja, so.
Das werde ich mir als nächstes geben, ja.
hätte auch gerne ein terminal aqua kann man mir das bei casa ja nicht bei casa
bei danki ja das ist auch keine gute ist auch keine gute idee
bei park zettel lesen ist auch ist auch echt keine keine gute idee
Hast du gehört?
Black Ops 2 und Black Ops 1.
Ja, habe ich gehört.
Ich habe aber keine PS5.
Ich habe nur eine Old, Old, Old School PS4.
Und ich komme mit dem Controller nicht mehr klar.
Ja.
den er auch viel Kohle bringt.
Ich bin in Top-Verfassung, Leute,
für mein Alter.
Ich bin wirklich in Top-Verfassung.
Haben die mir alle erzählt.
Auch Blutbild und alles,
alles super. Ich hab nix, gar nix.
Das Einzige, was ich hab,
ist, ich bin ein bisschen zu dick.
Aber ansonsten ist gar nix.
Blutbild, top in Ordnung.
EKG, top in Ordnung.
Ruhepuls und alles top in Ordnung
Was auch immer
Blutzucker, alles top in Ordnung
Alles super
Aber trotzdem mache ich mir teilweise übelste Gedanken
Und mittlerweile
Das hat tatsächlich die Therapie auch ein bisschen was gebracht
Mittlerweile
Sage ich mir einfach immer
Scheiß drauf
Und selbst wenn ich irgendwas habe
Es wird mich schon nicht umbringen, scheiß drauf
Das hilft bei mir ganz gut
Werbung, oh, Chat, Werbung
Günstige Storage
Und Ukraine Nasses
Gibt's bei mir
Über den Link im Banner
Beziehungsweise im Kanalprofil
Oder Ausrufezeichen Ukraine, Ausrufezeichen Seagate
Und wohlgemerkt, die Preise sind wirklich günstig
Und die Preise gibt es nur über meinen Link
Sonst nicht
Und wer braucht nicht gerade Storage?
Oder Nass kann auch jeder gebrauchen
Deswegen habe ich auch 5
Ne, habe ich nicht
Ich habe
3 plus 1 Nasse habe ich aktuell
RAM?
Soll ich die mal anschreiben, ob Alternet auch ein bisschen RAM sponsoren kann?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Alternet das macht
Also Alternet direkt habe ich eh keinen Kontakt
Ich glaube nicht, dass Ram aktuell in irgendeiner Art und Weise günstiger gibt.
Ich wollte hier noch was zu Konzerten erzählen.
Also wie gesagt, mir ist es an der Seite sitzen, wenn es so ein bisschen hoch geht, lieber.
Weil wie gesagt, ich bin nur 1,74.
Ich sehe meistens, wenn ich vorne stehe, nicht so viel.
Und das Heftigste, was ich mal hatte, ist, das ist ewig her.
Rock am Ring, keine Ahnung.
oder irgendwie sowas.
Warte mal. Rock am Ring?
Da habe ich doch sogar mal kommentiert auf
auf YouTube.
Findet Google Suche das?
Ne.
In 2001 war es nicht.
Zumindest
bei Rock am Ring damals
da stand ich auch ganz vorne
und
also und
ich hab halt
doch ganz gut was gesehen, weil wir relativ weit vorne waren
die Bühne ist ja ein bisschen höher
aber ich hab keine Luft mehr gekriegt
das ist wirklich
um mich drum herum standen nur größere
Leute, die haben mir die Luft weggeatmet
ich hab keine Luft mehr gekriegt
ich hab gedacht, ich ersticke
das war echt, seitdem bin ich
da nicht mal so scharf drauf, ganz vorne
im Pulk zu stehen
Das war wirklich heftig
Das hat dann nur funktioniert
Weil ich hab übelst Panik gekriegt
Und ich hab mich dann aber wieder beruhigt
Und dann ging es auch wieder mit Atmen
Also das war echt nix
Das war wirklich nix
Ich hab schon gedacht
Ich muss über die Absperrung hüpfen
Da wo die ganzen Sanitäter stehen
Normalerweise wäre ich auch nie so weit vorgegangen
Aber
und ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch Trick 17 ist,
bei so Open Air Sachen oder irgendwelchen Festivals,
wenn man nach vorne will,
als Kerl hast du es sehr schwer durchzukommen.
Was geht ist, wenn du Mädels dabei hast,
die werden immer durchgelassen.
Das heißt, die müssen dich mitziehen.
Also entgegen dem, was man eigentlich so glaubt,
so nach dem Motto, als Kerl musst du vorne weg,
machst du Platz, Blödsinn.
Du musst die Mädels vorne weglaufen lassen.
Die schnappen dich dann.
Die nehmen dich an der Hand und ziehen sich hinter dir her.
Da kommst du viel besser durch bei solchen Veranstaltungen,
wie wenn du als Kerl vorne wegläufst.
Sexismus, ja.
Siehst du?
Zack.
Und, Funds denn noch?
Ich bräuchte übrigens auch, wo wir gerade wieder dabei sind,
ich bräuchte wirklich noch einen 8-Gig.
Was habe ich hier eigentlich für RAM
drinne aktuell?
Ich meine, ich habe 8-Gig drinne. Steht da auch drinne,
was man hier für einen RAM hat?
Ne, oder? Oh, Chat,
das ist eine gute Frage.
Kann man unter Linux rauskriegen,
was man für einen RAM hat?
Ja, geht bestimmt, oder?
Man kann doch dieses DIMM-Zeug
auslesen unter Linux.
Linux
Linux, check which RAM
Speed
Genau, das hier habe ich gesucht
Das hier habe ich gesucht
Ja, ja, permission denied
Ich bin nicht gut, ich weiß
So, wir haben
5600er
RAM-Riegel tatsächlich.
Ich dachte eigentlich, ich hätte da langsameren
RAM drin.
Also unter Windows hätte ich
absolut keine Ahnung, wie ich unter...
Ey, ohne Scheiß, wie gucke ich unter Windows nach,
was für ein RAM-Speed ich habe? Bestimmt nicht im
Task Manager, oder?
Also mit
Bordmitteln.
Task Manager? Wirklich?
Sieht man das da?
Performance? Wo denn?
Performance?
Da steht's.
Wo? Wo?
Wo, wo, wo, wo steht's?
Bei Performance unten rechts.
4.800.
Wie, warum ist das so lahm?
Ich hab...
Warum ist das so langsam?
Ich hab krasses Overclock-Ram.
Sekunde.
Ich hab...
Ich hab das hier.
6.400.
Warum, warum...
WTF?
Warum ist mein Ram so langsam?
Ja, ich hab das Memory-Profil nicht aktiviert, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Weil der RAM ist nicht mit 6400 gelaufen, obwohl es damit verkauft wird.
Ich hab ab und zu Blue-Screens gehabt.
Aber ich dachte, wenn ich das auf Default stelle, dann macht er wenigstens 5600 und nicht 4800 daraus.
Ach, weißt du was? Scheiß drauf.
Ich habe trotzdem genug Performance.
Guck mal, der Rahmen in meinem Mini-PC ist schneller als der Rahmen in meinem Desktop.
Aber ich könnte wirklich noch einen...
Ich könnte wirklich noch ein 8 Gig...
Ein 8 Gig...
DDR3.
Ne, ne, ne.
Behalte deinen Rammer.
Ramverschenken ist wie Geld verschenken.
Das will ich nicht.
Außerdem, so arm bin ich nicht.
Ich kann mir das schon selbst kaufen.
Danke für das Angebot.
Ne, ne.
Behalte es mal lieber selbst.
Okay
Also sowas hier
Auf was bezieht sich denn
Ein RX16
Ich würde Ram überhaupt nicht verkaufen
Ich würde es gerade immer behalten.
Also ich weiß nicht, was
1RX16 bedeuten soll.
Du willst Dual Rank idealerweise.
Ach Quatsch, für meinen D-Lux Mini-PC ist mir das wurscht.
Da kommt rein, was
reinkommt.
Guck mal.
Guck mal Leute.
Von fucking 25 Euro
auf 125.
Omega 0.
Ja, die
IGPU juckt mich nicht. Ich spiele da nichts drauf.
Aber hast schon recht.
Stonks.
Geht steil bergauf.
Ja, so 8 GIG könnte ich halt
tatsächlich noch gebrauchen.
Weil 16
sollten schon sein.
Auf der anderen Seite,
ich bin hier nicht am RAM-Limit, aber
Chat, wir haben schon lange
keine Frontend-Sachen
mehr gebaut.
Sondern wenn man nämlich Frontend-Sachen baut,
dann brauche ich eine IDE
am Laufen für die Backend-Sachen,
Visual Studio Code fürs Frontend,
Browser Tabs,
das ist immer sehr Memory-intensiv,
Frontend-Sachen, beziehungsweise Web-Anwendungen
zu bauen.
Also jetzt nicht für die Web-Anwendungen
an sich, sondern für die Entwicklungstools.
Und am schlimmsten war,
wo ich mal
in
was in Go programmiert
hab,
was ich dann aus dem C-Sharp
Programm, ich weiß, hört sich abgedreht an, aber haben wir im Stream
mal gemacht, ich hab was in Go
programmiert,
ähm,
exportiert, dass man es per C-API
callen kann und dann von C-Sharp
aus das Go
Programm, also die Go-Funktion
aufgerufen.
Ja, wirres Zeug haben wir aber mal gemacht.
Und dazu gab es dann noch WebRTC im Frontend.
Das heißt, ich hatte offen Goland, Rider, also hier JetBrains Gedöns, und Visual Studio Code und Browser.
Das hat, glaube ich, allein schon irgendwie 20 GB RAM gefressen.
Rust haben wir auch gemacht.
Ich habe dann versucht, weil ich selbst festgestellt habe, dass es doch nicht so clever war, das in Go zu machen, habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache das in Rust, weil Interop mit Rust ist halt deutlich einfacher wie Interop mit Go und auch schneller.
Nicht, dass Performance-Probleme da jetzt wirklich Probleme gewesen wären.
Das haben wir auch gemacht. Dann hatten wir Rust Rover offen, Rider und Visual Studio Code.
Verstehst jedes Wort.
Das sind...
IDEs.
Propaganda-Beef.
Guck hier.
Rastrover, Rider.
Weißt du, was eine IDE ist?
Wenn du hier bist, weißt du das bestimmt, oder?
iPad Chat.
IDE ist ein Texteditor.
Mit mehr Funktionen.
IDE ist der SATA-Vorgänger.
Stimmt, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Du hast recht.
IDE.
Chat, wer von euch ist alt genug und hatte noch IDE-Festplatten oder IDE-CD-ROM-Laufwerke und sowas?
Haben wir so alte Leute hier?
Okay, hatten wir. Beste.
Und könnt ihr euch noch...
Jumper setzen, genau.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
dass man gucken musste,
bei IDE-Kabeln, ja die sahen dann so aus,
dass du gucken musstest,
dass du dein CD-Laufwerk und die Festplatte in der richtigen Reihenfolge anschließt und richtig jumperst,
weil ansonsten das CD-Laufwerk deine Festplatte langsam gemacht hat.
Das war ganz, ganz wirres Zeug.
Ich habe es bis heute nicht richtig verstanden, ja.
Aber das war damals so.
Ich glaube, die Farben sind auch extra dafür gemacht.
So, an das Blaue soll die Festplatte, an das Graue dann das CD-Laufwerk.
Oder vielleicht auch umgedreht.
Und noch was, und noch was. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kennt ihr noch das Ding?
Äh, Floppy.
Das Floppy-Disk-Kabel mit, genau, mit diesem Knick drin.
Chat, ich habe bis heute keine Ahnung, wofür dieser Knick da ist.
Komm, lass uns das jetzt mal erklären.
Warum, wofür...
Wofür ist der Knick da?
Okay.
Gibt es da vielleicht einfach noch eine kurze Erklärung?
Ich will das jetzt nicht
Alter, so genau will ich es gar nicht wissen
WTF, der will es aber
Der ist aber hier sehr ausführlich mit der Erklärung
Okay
Fragen wir mal die KI
Why floppy cable twisted?
Komm, wir fragen mal die China-KI, was die dazu sagt.
To avoid manually setting jumpers on drives.
Aha.
A hardware hack introduced by IBM.
Ist das so?
Guck mal, was die China-Chinesen dazu sagen.
Ah, classic question.
Crossover LAN-Kabel.
Der Sinba-Crossover-LAN-Kabel, den verstehe ich ja noch.
Der Sinba-Crossover-LAN-Kabel war, dass nicht Sende...
Sende-Pin auf Sende-Pin ist.
Das war der Sinba-Crossover-LAN-Kabel, ja?
Dass Sende-Pin auf Empfangspin ist und Empfangspin auf Sende-Pin.
Das verstehe ich ja noch.
Weil mittlerweile braucht man das nicht mehr, das erkennen die Netzwerkkarten selbst.
Das habe ich ja noch verstanden.
Aber warum muss das bei dem Floppy-Disk-Laufwerk so sein?
Automatically assigned drive letters
Was?
Okay
Das glaube ich
Was hat es mit drive letters zu tun?
Keiner weiß, was mit Hardware Detection zu tun zu haben
Lernt man noch was?
Gut, dann würde ich sagen
Gucken wir mal
Was auf GitHub so trendet
Warum es das gibt, verstehe ich auch nicht
Warum es da zwei Möglichkeiten gibt
Wie man da quasi die Adern auflegt
Das check ich auch nicht
warum es da zwei verschiedene Varianten gibt.
Letztendlich ist es auch egal,
solange beide Seiten
gleich aufgelegt werden vom Kabel.
Wisst ihr,
was noch oldschooliger ist
als Crossover-LAN-Kabel?
Die Dinger.
Das war noch Zeiten hier.
10 Base 2.
Mit Terminator.
Das habe ich glaube ich schon 100 Mal erzählt.
Aber ich fand das so geil damals, das Zeug.
Das war ein Netzwerkkabel damals.
Mit einem T-Stück.
Das kam an die Netzwerkkarte.
Und der letzte in dieser Kette.
Also ihr seht, das wurde immer nur durchgeschleift.
Es gab da keinen Switch oder sowas dazwischen.
Das wurde immer nur durchgeschleift und am Ende, quasi der letzte in dieser Kette, der musste sich so einen Terminator drauf machen.
Sonst gab es Reflektionen und das Netzwerk ging nicht.
Warst du bei der Erfindung des Feuers dabei?
Passt.
Null Modem. Null Modem Kabel waren auch nice.
Da gab es aber zwei Stück von.
Es gab einmal die seriellen Nullmodem-Kabels und etwas schneller waren die parallelen Nullmodem-Kabels, Leute.
Nullmodem-Kabel war das erste, was ich mit Netzwerk gemacht habe in meinem Leben.
Kennst du noch Vampirklemmen?
Ey, das sagt mir nix.
Nullmodemkabel, da habe ich damals
meinen Rechner mit dem Rechner vom Kollege verbunden
aus der Schule
und wir haben uns richtig krass Hackerman gefühlt
und das war damals ja auch ein riesen Akt
du musstest damals unter Windows
musstest du irgendwie in die Netzwerkumgebung
NetBIOS aktivieren
NetBIOS über TCP aktivieren
SPX, TCP IP
hinzufügen
NetBOI aktivieren, das war ganz
ganz furchtbar wie das Zeug, bis das
funktioniert hat. Und dann hat es auch in der Hälfte
der Fälle nicht richtig funktioniert.
Wie schnell waren Netzwerke über parallel?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
384k
kann es sein?
Mal gucken.
How fast?
Ne.
So viel?
Steht da auch irgendwie die Geschwindigkeit?
Das war ja kein Modem.
Das war ja wirklich nur ein Kabel.
Was steht da gerade drin?
Was sagt dein Chat-GPT dazu?
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Vielleicht waren es auch 512.
Okay.
500 Kilo.
Weit.
Das ist ja richtig schnell gewesen.
Also für die damalige Zeit und für den Aufwand, der dahinter steckt.
Das war ja die einfachste Variante, wie du zwei Rechner miteinander verbinden konntest.
Das erste...
Ich glaube, das erste Multiplayer-Spiel, was ich auf dem PC gespielt habe, im Kollegen zusammen,
war Siedler 2 Splitscreen-Multiplayer.
Das hier.
Da konntest du an einem PC
An einem PC
Konntest du zwei Mäuse anschließen
Und einer hat auf der linken Seite
Gespielt, einer hat auf der rechten Seite gespielt
Eigentlich mega nice
Gibt's heute nicht mehr
Mir fällt kein Spiel ein, was das heute in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch ermöglichen würde
Siedler 2, Splitscreen mit zwei Mäusen
Wie kriegt man zwei PS1 Mäuse dran?
Gar nicht
Das ist eine serielle Maus
Hast du dann angeschlossen
Gab es sowas wie
Gab es irgendwie so einen Port Multiplexer
Für PS1
Ich meine jetzt nicht die Playstation
Ich meine den Port
Ne USB hatte man damals noch nicht
Gab noch kein USB
Und wo wir gerade bei alten
Wo wir gerade bei alten Kabeln sind, Leute
Wo wir gerade bei alten Kabeln sind
Kennt noch einer dieses Ding?
Dieses Teil hier
Übrigens nicht USB auf der Seite
Keck, wait, Alter
Das da
Damit hast du früher Drucker angeschlossen
LPT
Es kann sein, dass die Dinge LPT hießen, ja
Drucker hast du
damals angeschlossen, ja
Es war ein Parallelport hier auf der
Seite am PC
Und dieses komische Ding
Ich hab nie verstanden, warum Drucker
diesen komischen Anschluss haben
und nicht einfach auch ein Parallelport
auf der anderen Seite, so ein ganz normaler Parallelportstecker
Das hab ich nie gecheckt, warum das so ist
Aber Drucker hatten diesen komischen
Anschluss
Drucker waren schon immer Curse
Ja, das stimmt
Muss sagen
Seit ich keinen Tintenstrahldrucker mehr hab
Läuft es zu
99% der Fälle
Klat mit dem Drucken
Ich hab mir vor ein paar Jahren
Mal gedacht
Nachdem ich meinen Tintenstrahldrucker wieder abgefuckt hab
Ich druck ja nur ein paar mal im Jahr
Und jedes Mal hat mein Tintenstrahldrucker rumgespackt
Da hab ich mir gedacht
Ich gebe einfach mal ein bisschen Geld aus und habe mir einen Farblazer Drucker gekauft mit Scanner.
Dementsprechend kannst du damit auch kopieren und theoretisch hat er sogar noch einen Faxanschluss.
Aber da habe ich natürlich nichts dran angeschlossen.
Und seitdem habe ich so gut wie keine Probleme mehr mit meinem Drucker.
Die Airprint Geschichte übers WLAN funktioniert wunderbar.
Vom Desktop ausdrucken, ohne jegliche Probleme
Alles top
Der Feinstaub
Ich hab noch nicht mal Probleme mit Feinstaub
Weil ich hab das in der Abstellkammer stehen
In der Abstellkammer stehen, den Drucker
Den hab ich nicht hier bei mir
im Büro stehen.
Wer faxt denn bitte schön? Deutsche Behörden
stehen sehr oft gefaxen.
Hast du gestern das Fußballspiel gesinnen?
Juckt mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Es ist mir, es ist wirklich,
es könnte mir kaum egaler sein.
Aber wo wir gerade dabei sind,
haben wir gewonnen?
Also ich weiß, dass Deutschland
gespielt hat gegen die Elfenbeinküste
und ich weiß, es ging um 22 Uhr los.
So, das weiß ich. Mehr weiß ich nicht.
Wir haben gewonnen.
Wie? Natürlich.
Warst du nicht daran beteiligt?
Also.
Ah ja, ist so.
Gerade junge
Leute sind sicherlich
sehr perplex, wenn sie das erste Mal
einen Fax verschicken sollen.
Ich meine, zu Recht, faxen ist halt irgendwie
sowas von 1990.
Aber in Deutschland wird immer noch
ganz gerne gefaxt.
Der Stream war langsamer als die Nachbarn.
Ja gut, das ist in der heutigen Zeit
tatsächlich ein Problem.
Oh, ich habe lange kein CS,
kein Competitive CS mehr geguckt.
Das ist eigentlich nicht mein Selbstspiel, da hab ich irgendwie keinen Bock mehr
Das ist halt echt so ein bisschen problematisch
Mittlerweile hast du zig Varianten, wie du Livestreams empfangen kannst
Und bei den meisten Streams ist es ja auch egal
Aber bei Sportstreams, gerade bei so großen Ereignissen, wo dann der Nachbar schon jubelt
während bei einem im Stream der Typ noch nicht mal losgelaufen ist.
Das ist halt ein bisschen kacke.
Was ich richtig cringe finde irgendwie,
dass es mittlerweile sogar Latency Booster gibt.
Du sollst extra dafür bezahlen und sowas.
Aber es gibt einen Trick.
Also keine Ahnung, ob das ein gangbarer Trick ist,
aber es gibt einen Trick.
Du kannst dir einfach Kopfhörer aufsetzen
mit Noise Cancelling.
Dann hörst du nicht, wenn die Nachbarn jubeln.
Und es ist wie, als wärst du live dabei.
Also den Sound vom Stream auf die Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer.
Oder mit den Nachbarn zusammen gucken.
So social bin ich nicht, das wisst ihr doch.
Aber ich hab nette Nachbarn.
Auf beiden Seiten.
Das einzige, was mal ein bisschen weirdchamp war
Ist zu Corona-Zeiten
Wo mir mein einer Nachbar erzählt hat
Er glaubt, Corona ist eine Strafe Gottes
Oder eine Strafe Allahs, muss man bei ihm ja sagen
Aber eine Strafe Gottes
Hab ich auch gedacht, okay, alles klar
Was sollst du da drauf jetzt sagen?
Gibt halt so Leute, ne?
Stimmt wenigstens wenigsten sagt er das es gibt es ja
Was sagt er sagt er zur hitze weil sie nicht habe ich mit ihm noch nicht drüber geredet ich werde auch garantiert nicht
Darauf ansprechen ob das bei der hitze auch so ist
Ich glaube ganz viele gläubige leute sind bei sind bei
unangenehmen Ereignisse immer der Meinung,
es muss eine Strafe Gottes sein und sowas.
Wenn man gläubig ist,
ist das wahrscheinlich auch total naheliegend.
Weil die denken ja oftmals auch so nach dem Motto,
es ist alles schon vorherbestimmt und so.
Was auch immer.
Ich kann damit nichts anfangen, egal welche
Glaubensrichtungen.
Die einzigen Sachen, die ich teilweise
lese auf Twitter,
was so
mit Religion zu tun hat,
ich lese mir ab und zu Tweets vom
Dalai Lama durch.
Das habe auch alles.
Max, was ist dein Sternzeichen?
Kappa.
Das ist doch ein Sternzeichen, oder?
Ist Kappa nicht ein Sternzeichen?
Max hat es trinken sehr gut sehr gut
und wenn ich habe es dreimal getrunken ich muss auch zweimal trinken also
einmal noch
exzellent so
Was? So was schreibt der Papst auf Twitter, ja?
Stimmt, der hat doch letztens irgendwas zu KI veröffentlicht.
Das habe ich sogar auf irgendeiner Newsseite sogar gelesen,
dass der Papst irgendwas zu KI veröffentlicht hat.
Aber gelesen habe ich das natürlich nicht.
Moin, Comax.
Danke für den Sub.
So, jetzt kann man nur sagen,
Massive Subscription
Gut, dann schauen wir doch mal
Nachdem wir uns jetzt irgendwelche Oldschool
Kabel angeguckt haben
Über psychische Erkrankungen
Geredet haben, über
Ersticken bei Rock am Ring
Und sonstige Dinger
Und auf was für Konzerte ich als nächstes gehen will
Gehen wir mal über zu normalen Themen
Wieder heute im Stream und zwar
was trendet denn bei GitHub?
Ich darf jetzt auf der Arbeit
mit Proxmox rumspielen. Macht Spaß.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Proxmox ist auch nice.
Ich glaube, wo man sich aber ein bisschen davon
verabschieden muss,
und ich kann gleich sagen, falls mich jetzt einer
nach harten Gründen fragt, warum das so ist,
kann ich es nicht beantworten,
weil ich damit nicht viel zu tun habe.
Ich glaube, was man sich aber abschminken muss,
ist, dass Proxmox ein vollständiger Ersatz
für Vmware werden kann.
Ich kann euch das jetzt nicht mit harten Argumenten belegen, weil ich selbst kein VMware-Pro bin und auch noch nie größere Business Enterprise VMware-Installationen supportet habe.
Aber ich höre das oft von VMware-Leuten.
Und VMware-Leute sind nicht wirklich große VMware-Fans seit es Broadcom ist.
Also sie würden sich sicherlich, also zumindest die, die ich kenne, sicherlich auch was anderes angucken, beziehungsweise haben sich das angeguckt und die sind, also ich habe noch von keinem das Gegenteil gehört, der sagt, ja easy, VMware durch Proxmox ersetzen.
Also ich glaube Proxmox ist eine super Virtualisierungslösung auf KVM Basis, aber wenn man in diesem VMware Ökosystem drin ist und da alles drumherum verwendet von VMware, dann ist glaube ich Proxmox kein Ersatz.
VirtualBox
Wie kommt man auf sowas
Für was VirtualBox
Für
Für Server Virtualisierung
Oder was
Ja das ist eine bescheuerte Idee
Läuft VirtualBox überhaupt gescheit Headless
Und wenn man eh unter Linux ist
Kann man doch einfach KVM
Verwenden
Wenn man schon gerne manuell Sachen macht
Okay, das werde ich nicht verstehen
Das haben wahrscheinlich aber Leute entschieden, die keinen Plan haben, was sie da machen
Für Desktop-Virtualisierung ist Virtualbox okay
Ja, also ob man jetzt vor allem mal Workstation verwendet auf dem Desktop
Oder Virtualbox, würde ich sagen
Früher hätte ich gesagt, vor allem mal Workstation all the way
Mittlerweile, nachdem vor allem mal Workstation immer beschissener wird
Würde ich sagen, geht genauso gut Virtualbox
Hat jemand Nutanix probiert?
Ich kenne einen, ehemaliger Kollege von mir aus der Berufsschule, arbeitet bei Nutanix.
Aber ausprobiert habe ich es noch nicht.
Die wollten beim alten Arbeitgeber, wollten die uns das mal verkaufen.
Da habe ich den wieder getroffen.
Und seitdem habe ich den Namen ab und zu mal gehört, aber nie was mit zu tun gehabt.
Wie sieht denn das so aus?
Zeig mal her.
Wie sieht denn das Webinterface aus?
Wir lassen uns ja von äußeren Werten
erstmal beeindrucken.
Äh.
Und wo macht man da jetzt VMs an und aus?
Hier.
Ah, so sieht das aus.
Ne.
Hä?
Ich bin schon mal zu blöd,
fast ein Webinterface zu finden.
Okay, hier.
Naja, das sieht zumindest nicht aus wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend,
das Webinterface.
Was wird daran immer beschissener?
Du meinst bei VMware?
Na zum Beispiel, also das ist jetzt so eine Sache,
die mich übelst abgefuckt hat.
Also bei VMware Workstation meine ich, ne?
Wir reden hier nicht von ESX oder sowas.
Zum Beispiel,
dass seit VMware Workstation 26,
wenn du dort...
Das hier brauchen wir.
wenn du dort accelerate 3d graphics anmachst im bios und und und du dann
ins bios gehst dass die tastatur übelst rum klatscht
hast zum beispiel hier machen wir mal an machen pxe boot auf pxe boot geht jetzt
Ja
Und wenn du das jetzt neu startest
Warte mal
Wir wollen
EFI Network
Ja
Und wenn du das jetzt ein paar mal neu startest
Dann laggt die Tastatur
Also du drückst dann nach oben und nach unten
Und du landest dann nicht mehr oben
Und unten
Sondern bei Enter und sowas
Das ist jetzt verbuggt
Vor allem bei Workstation 26
Ja
Manchmal funzt es
Guck, jetzt funktioniert schon wieder nichts.
Seht ihr das?
Jetzt musste ich erst...
Guck mal, ich drücke jetzt Enter.
Enter.
Ich muss zweimal Enter drücken.
Das ist verbuggt.
Also quasi alles, was vor dem Start des Betriebssystems läuft, ist die Tastatur verbuggt, wenn man 3D Acceleration anschaltet.
Guck, ich drücke jetzt Enter.
Passiert nichts.
Und dann muss ich Pfeil nach oben drücken, dass er Enter ausführt.
Und dann backt...
Also ganz, ganz, ganz wirres Zeug.
Und dann drückt er...
Guck, guck. Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Ich habe jetzt nur Pfeil nach unten gedrückt
und er ist rausgeklitscht.
Das ist so ein Ding, was mich mega abfuckt
bei VMware.
Workstation 26.
By the way,
wir können mal gucken, ob es neue Software-Updates gibt.
Check for updates.
Oh, guck mal.
26. Was ist denn
hier gedingst worden?
Vmware Workstation
is now 64-bit on Windows.
Okay.
Vielleicht
vielleicht fixt das Problem.
Äh, by the way.
Äh.
Wo ist eigentlich der Knopf für jetzt
updaten?
Gibt's den nicht mehr?
Wo wir grad bei Sachen sind, die sacken.
Den Knopf fürs updaten gibt's nicht mehr.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich es runterladen und dann neu installieren.
Naja.
Whatever.
Dann spielt vor allem der Workstation auch schlecht mit dieser ganzen Windows-Virtualisierungsgeschichte zusammen.
Wobei das Problem VirtualBox auch hat.
Ja, und wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen nachdenke, fallen mir noch mehr Sachen ein.
Also das ist die letzten Jahre über immer schlechter geworden, vor allem bei Workstation.
Ja, auf Half-Life 3 hätte ich mal richtig Bock.
Es gab ja dieses Jahr mal wieder Gerüchte.
Es gab ja dieses Jahr öfters mal wieder Gerüchte, dass die an Half-Life 3 arbeiten.
Aber wie gesagt, das glaube ich erst, wenn es wirklich offiziell angekündigt ist.
habt ihr eigentlich bei euch package mirror für npm und so weiter auf der
arbeit ja wir haben was auf der arbeit das nennt sich artefaktor das jay frog
artefaktor das kann repos proxien und repos mir an manche repos sind bei uns
gemeldet manche sind geproxiert du kannst auch repos selbst anlegen ja und interne
Sachen pushen.
Ja, das haben wir auf der Arbeit.
Ich muss sagen, ich war ursprünglich
überhaupt kein Fan von.
Aber mittlerweile,
ich hab mir gedacht, Alter, warum soll ich
meine Docker-Images über so einen Kack-Umweg ziehen,
wenn ich die auch direkt ziehen könnte?
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen,
nach den ganzen tausenden
Supply-Chain-Angriffen, die es die letzten
paar Jahre über gegeben hat,
ist das schon
nicht verkehrt.
Kann aber auch nicht alles aufhalten.
Nexus sagt mir was.
Kann das sein, dass Nexus...
Dass wir Nexus beim alten...
Beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten?
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ich glaube, mein alter Arbeitgeber hatte das.
Nexus.
Mir ist übrigens noch ein gutes Beispiel eingefallen aus dem Real Life.
Wir hatten es doch gestern im Stream von, dass es manchmal keinen Sinn macht, über was jahrelang zu meckern.
Und dass einen das auch nicht unbedingt jetzt gerade im besten Licht auf der Arbeit dastehen lässt, weil man immer nur alles scheiße findet.
Und dass ich mittlerweile dazu übergegangen bin, zu sagen, ey, ich finde das ist keine gute Idee.
aus den und den Gründen
und wenn dann irgendjemand an den Stellen,
der das entscheiden darf, entscheidet,
doch, wir machen das,
obwohl, also
unabhängig von den negativen Aspekten,
dass ich dann mittlerweile sage, ey, wisst ihr was,
ich halte das fest, dass das gesagt wurde
und dann mache ich das,
dann müsst ihr aber auch mit den Problemen leben.
So, mir ist ein Beispiel
dazu eingefallen, wo das
der Fall ist, bei uns auf der Arbeit.
jetzt erst relativ neu.
Und zwar
bei uns auf der Arbeit
wird überlegt,
ob man sich nicht auch
Windows Defender für Linux
anschaffen will. Und wer sich jetzt
fragt, was wie Windows Defender für Linux?
Ja, das gibt es.
Also falls das jemand nicht kannte,
das gibt es.
Das nennt sich dann nicht Windows Defender, das nennt sich glaube ich
Microsoft Endpoint
for Linux oder irgendwie sowas.
Microsoft Defender Endpunkt unter Linux
nennt sich das dann.
Nee, Red Hat muss auch supported sein.
Wenn Red Hat nicht supported ist, dann geht's bei uns ja nicht.
Aber das muss...
Mein alter Arbeitgeber hatte das auch und das lief unter
CentOS damals noch.
So. Also die überlegen sich gerade, ob sie das da
einführen sollen.
So, und ich habe eine lange E-Mail geschrieben
an die Leute, die das gerade
erproben,
was da dran kacke ist.
Unter anderem, also ich hatte
zwei Punkte, die mir jetzt gerade so
spontan noch einfallen ist.
Wir hatten richtige Probleme damit.
Wir mussten auf Oracle-Datenbanken
ganze Verzeichnisse whitelisten,
weil der Windows Defender
da irgendwelche komischen Dinger
gemacht hat mit den Verzeichnissen,
in dem die Datenbank ihre Daten liegen hat, sodass die Datenbanken teilweise ultra langsam gewesen sind.
Also wir mussten ganze Oracle quasi Datenbankverzeichnung exkluden, dass das überhaupt gescheit funktioniert.
So, das ist das eine.
Und...
Das andere fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Achso, und das andere ist, dass Microsoft Windows Defender Updates macht,
ohne sie als Windows Defender Updates zu kennzeichnen.
Also die machen Windows Defender Updates, also Softwareänderungen mit Virensignatur Updates.
Also dass regelmäßig Virensignaturen geupdatet werden ist ja klar, aber die machen während sie Virensignaturen einspielen auch Updates an Microsoft Defender selbst.
Also sie machen quasi Virensignaturen und Softwareupdates teilweise in einem und das hat bei uns zu Problemen geführt.
Wir hatten auf einmal morgens auf Filesurfern 40% mehr CPU-Last.
Und keiner wusste warum. Einfach so von heute auf morgen.
Und da habe ich gedacht, es war doch nichts, es wurde nichts geupdatet und sonst was.
Und was war? Bäm! Microsoft hat eine Antivirus-Abt... also eine Virensignatur geupdatet,
die einen Bug fabriziert haben in der Logik von Windows Defender.
Ach ja, und was damals auch so der Fall war, das weiß ich nicht, ob es heute noch so ist,
du konntest Windows Defender nur über irgendwelche offiziellen Azure-Dinger updaten
oder Microsoft-Dinge updaten und nicht über
einen eigenen Server.
Du musst es quasi freischalten ins Internet.
Oder irgendeine
Proxy eintragen.
Also das war kacke. So, zumindest
habe ich das zusammengeschrieben und an die Leute
geschickt bei uns auf der Arbeit, die das erproben.
Als Antwort
habe ich bekommen,
danke für den Hinweis.
Damit bestätigt sich ja quasi
das, was wir auch schon vermutet haben.
Also, sie haben mir quasi recht gegeben,
dass sie auch schon vermutet haben, das Produkt ist Schrott.
Aber, wir können
daran nichts machen. Das wurde schon auf
anderer Ebene entschieden.
Und da habe ich
mir so gedacht, wisst ihr was?
Ich speichere mir mal die E-Mail,
sodass die nicht
archiviert wird oder sonst was, dass ich die immer griffbereit
habe. Und wenn wir mal Probleme
haben wegen Windows Defender, dann knall
ich euch das wieder auf den Tisch und sag, guck dir mal
da, ist ja nicht so,
als hätte keiner was gesagt.
Selbst dran schuld.
Erzählt mir jetzt nicht, das liegt dann irgendwie in unseren Linux-Kisten
oder sonst was.
Selbst dran schuld. Ihr wolltet das so, ihr habt das so entschieden.
Ihr müsst auch damit leben.
Aber es hat keinen Sinn,
dass ich mich jetzt gefühlt auf jedem
Weekly-Meeting oder so da hinstelle
oder auf jedem TrueFix oder
Service-Meeting oder was wir haben, mit tausend Sachen
hinstelle und darüber ablästere,
dass Windows Defender kacke ist.
Die Leute, die das entscheiden können, haben das entschieden.
Hoffentlich mit den Infos, dass es kacke ist.
Und wenn sie das so entschieden haben, dann kriegen sie das auch so.
Und wenn es halt Probleme gibt und es vielleicht Ausfälle verursacht, die Millionen kosten,
was ich mir bei unserem System durchaus vorstellen kann, selbst dran schuld.
Mehr als sagen und sogar noch schriftlich kann ich nicht.
CouchDB. Ist CouchDB nicht diese Java-Geschichte?
Diese integrierte Java-Datenbank? Ist es nicht das?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durch?
Warum haben sie keinen unabhängigen Alpeter genommen?
Kaspersky oder Bitdefender?
Kaspersky hatten die, glaube ich mal.
Oder haben die immer noch für Fileserver und sowas.
Aber anscheinend gibt es da nicht so viel Konkurrenz zu Windows Defender, was das angeht.
Weil das macht ja nicht nur Virensignaturen, das macht ja auch irgendwie Verhaltenserkennung und irgendwelche On-the-Fly-Threat-Detection und sonst was.
Wahrscheinlich hat Microsoft da das bessere Paket.
Ja, keine Ahnung warum.
Letztendlich ist das alles scheiße.
Ich will das alles auf meinem Linux-Server nicht haben.
Ach ne, Apache ist das.
Ne, doch, Apache CouchDB.
Relax.
Weiter muss ich schon mal gar nicht lesen.
Weiter muss ich schon mal gar nicht lösen.
Erlang.
Monk HS.
Wollen die besonders viele Klammern haben, oder wie?
Erlang, Alter.
Wer macht denn freiwillig was in Erlang?
Sind die Leute schon komplett geistig durch, oder was?
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Erlang hat seine Fans, okay.
Aber ich bin kein Erlang-Fan.
Es sei denn, man möchte besonders viele Klammern machen.
Dann ist Erlang toll.
Max, hattet ihr mal ein Rootkit auf der Arbeit?
Ja, hatten wir.
Aber ratet mal...
Sekunde.
Hier, zack.
Also die Frage ist, Max, hattet ihr mal ein Rootkit auf der Arbeit?
Hatten wir.
Ratet mal, welche
Server und Clients nicht betroffen waren.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten.
Was war nicht betroffen? Linux!
Richtig! Unsere Linux-Server
waren nicht betroffen und unsere
Linux-Laptops waren nicht betroffen.
Es war wohl so,
also ich kann
euch nicht sagen, welches Root-Kit oder so.
Es war wohl so,
irgendein Dienstleister
hat Daten
angeliefert über einen
uralten
SFTP-Server,
der auf Windows-Basis läuft.
Allein schon das ist eine sehr
merkwürdige Kombination.
Windows, alt, SFTP.
Fragt mich nicht, ist aber so gewesen.
Es gab einen uralten
Windows-Server, der quasi offen war
für Partnerunternehmen, dort
über SFTP Daten anzuliefern.
Darüber wurden irgendwelche manipulierten Dateien angeliefert, die auf diesem Windows irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken ausgelutzt haben, um darauf Rechte zu bekommen.
Das Problem war, und das kriege ich jetzt nicht mehr hundertprozentig zusammen, das Problem war aber wohl irgendwie, dass es dort dann noch einen Admin-Account gab, auf diesem Windows-Rechner, der Active Directory, der höhere Rechte im Active Directory hatte.
Das heißt, die konnten sich quasi nicht nur auf diesem Windows-Server breit machen, sondern konnten von diesem Windows-Server aus die Active Directory Software-Verteilung beeinflussen.
Und die haben dann irgendwelche Keylogger und Gedöns installiert.
Und wisst ihr, wie das aufgefallen ist, dass die Windows-Clients sowas installiert hatten?
Unter anderem ist es als einem der ersten ist es damals meinem Chef aufgefallen.
Und zwar hat mein Chef auf sein, wie nennt man das, sein persönliches Netzwerklaufwerk geguckt.
Also jeder User hat quasi für Daten zum Ablegen so ein privates Netzlaufwerk gehabt.
Und auf seinem privaten Netzlaufwerk lag eine TXT-Datei mit allen seinen Keypass-Passwörtern.
Oder hat er sich gefragt
Wie kommen die denn da hin
Und dann haben sie sich das ein bisschen näher angeguckt
Und dann haben sie festgestellt
Okay sie hatten Software, sie hatten Keylogger drauf
Sie hatten quasi so einen
Lese aus RAM Passwörter aus für Keypass
Und so drauf installiert
Und da war richtig die Kacke am Dampfen Leute
Aber massiv die Kacke am Dampfen
Das ist aber das einzige Mal, wo ich mich dran erinnern kann, dass wir sowas auf der
Arbeit hatten.
Und welche Server waren nicht betroffen?
Natürlich die Linux Server und die Linux Clients.
Wir hatten ja damals Linux Laptops, durften wir noch Linux drauf installieren selbst und
waren natürlich nicht betroffen
werbung ausrufezeichen ukraine ausrufezeichen seagate günstige festplatten
günstige nassus nur über meinen link in der beschreibung oder über den chat
nicht in der beschreibung im twitch kanal about page mit linux wäre das
nicht passiert. Ja.
Wir machen externe Pentests.
Ob die Geschäftsleiter
und die Geschäftsführung dabei angegriffen werden,
du meinst mit irgendwelchen Phishing-Mails und sowas.
Keine Ahnung. Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ja. Weiß ich nicht.
Ne, und der Linux-Wert, das allein schon nicht
passiert, weil da ist nichts mit
Active Directory und da ist auch nichts mit komischen
mit komischer
Softwareverteilung,
aber du hast prinzipiell natürlich
recht, ja.
Es ist nicht so, als wäre Linux nicht angreifbar.
Wir haben in die letzten paar Wochen
ganz viele lokale Root-Exploits
gehabt für Linux.
Dirty-Frag,
Copy-Fail, was nicht
alles gab. Also da gab es in letzter Zeit
schon viel. Letztendlich kann ich
das unter Linux genauso treffen.
Mein Heimserver braucht 3-5 Watt mehr, als ich von Proxmox 18 auf 19...
Was?
Ne, du meinst von Proxmox 8 auf 9, oder?
Nicht von 18 auf 19, oder?
Oder ist es 1,8?
Keine Ahnung, ist auch egal.
Ja, das ist aber kacke.
Dann braucht mein Nasja auch mehr.
Hast du schon mal Power Top?
Power Top ausgeführt?
Ah ja.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Brauche ich...
Und C-States?
Sind weniger C-States, oder?
Oder macht das Ding einfach mehr?
Hatten wir hier nicht so eine...
Die Modes TXT, doch.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir erstmal, was auf GitHub trendet.
Nicht für Go, sondern insgesamt.
Die werden wie üblich...
alles was mit KI zu tun hat erstmal überspringen.
Es sei denn irgendwas spricht mich direkt an
und ich finde es interessant, aber ansonsten
alles KI. So, als erstes schon können wir überspringen.
AI.
IP-TV-Channels from all over the world.
Okay.
Für die Stream-Champs
unter uns. AI.
IP-Adresses break...
Was?
Muss ich das verstehen?
Was soll das sein?
Modular Network Stack in Rust.
Aha.
Bei Public Keys.
Wild und Quick.
Was sich alles gibt.
Okay, abgedrehter Pfeifert-Shit.
Ey, ich...
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich hätte so gern beispielsweise auf YouTube ein Toggle, was jeglichen KI-Content rausfiltert.
Ich höre ja ganz gern auch mal so Musik-Compilations und so auf YouTube.
Und mittlerweile kannst du dir das nicht mehr angucken.
Alles, was neuer ist als 5 oder 4 Jahre, kannst du nicht mehr anmachen,
weil davon gefühlt 80% irgendwelche billige KI-Musik sind, die ich nicht hören will.
Warum blinkt mein PC
Lahnkabelbuchse, weil der Strom so weit an ist
Dass du Power over
Wie heißt das? Wake on Lahn machen könntest
Du kannst ins Bios gehen
Und das wahrscheinlich
Wahrscheinlich, weiß man ja nicht, ob es bei dir so ist
Aber wahrscheinlich ausschalten
Zwei Minuten Werbung, da habe ich keinen Einfluss drauf
Wenn ich könnte, würde ich Werbung auf Twitch
Komplett ausschalten, weil ich verdiene daran
so gut wie nix.
Und da würde ich lieber ohne Werbung streamen
und ab und zu mal Sellout machen.
Der Wal.
Bin ich froh, dass das mit dem Wal
vorbei ist.
Okay, AI.
AI.
Was ist das?
Cloud Native Manager.
Aha.
Das habe ich schon mal gehört.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, was ist das?
Multi Cloud Kubernetes Management.
Was?
Aha.
Das ist ein Webinterface für Cloud-Ressourcen,
aber Cloud-Anbieter
übergreifend, oder wie?
Okay, das kann durchaus nützlich sein.
Azure.
Azure, Azure, Azure, Azure.
AWS.
Google stellt es dabei.
Kann doch ganz schön viel Kram.
Linux.
Ups.
Na gut.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
SWS.
Da habe ich jetzt auch schon öfters was von gehört.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, was es ist.
Irgendeine WebAssembly-Geschichte, glaube ich.
Super fast TypeScript
JavaScript Compiler written in Rust.
Okay.
Eine WebAssembly-Geschichte.
LM Cache.
AI.
PyTest.
Ne.
Achso.
Das ist quasi sowas wie
Postman.
Papetier,
Proc, auch schon öfters verwendet,
Browser-Automatisierung,
Chat-Wut,
Wot, Chat-Wot,
Open Source Live Chat, E-Mail Support,
Omni Channel Desk,
in Ruby, Leute!
Es gibt mal wieder eine Anwendung in Ruby!
Ah.
Ja, gut.
Nichts, was ich bräuchte, aber
ich find's cool, mal wieder
eine Ruby on Rails Anwendung zu sehen.
Also vermutlich ist es eine Ruby on Rails Anwendung.
Ja.
Sieht, sieht,
sieht Ruby on Rails mäßig aus.
Sieht Ruby on Rails besser.
Oh, Agile.
Agile.
Open Source.
Jira.
plane is a modern project management
platform to manage tasks, sprints
docs und
triage
triage wird
gemanagt
ok
ist das eine desktop anwendung
ich will für ein ticketsystem
keine desktop anwendung haben
geht das nicht über
einen browser
Self-hosted.
Get your license? What?
Das geht bestimmt auch per Webinterface, oder?
Puh.
Warum nicht?
wenn man sowas braucht.
Also ich für mich privat brauche sowas natürlich nicht.
Ich mache privat keine Sprints
und kein Sprintplanning
und kein Sprintreview
und keine Sprintretrospektive
und keine Surefixes.
Vielleicht bin ich
deswegen privat so unorganisiert
und bei mir sieht es so unordentlich aus.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal agiler werden
und täglich mit mir selbst Daily Scrum machen.
Daran wird es liegen.
Modernes Webzeug.
Teufelszeug.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
modernes Web finde ich wirklich eklig.
Eines meiner Sachen,
wo ich mich immer wieder drüber aufregen könnte,
ist Endless Scroll.
Endless Scrolling auf dem Desktop ist
komplett aus der Hölle
direkt.
Wir benutzen auch Jira.
Ganz ehrlich, von den ganzen Ticketsystemen,
die ich kenne, ist Jira noch das am wenigsten
nervige. Ich mag Jira eigentlich.
Der neue Tisch ist immer noch nicht aufgebaut.
Spoken Language.
Gibt es was, was in Deutsch trendet?
German.
Oh, Leute, hier trendet was.
Mit zwei Sternen auf Deutsch.
Dieses Repo ist jetzt Deutsch.
Äh, was, was, was?
Das ist ja auch wieder geil.
Was das für eine Software ist.
Ach hier.
Steuerung einer EVSE, DIN oder andere Ladepunkte für sofortiges...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Aber es ist auf Deutsch für Wallboxen.
Wir gucken mal, ob die Kommentare, falls es da Kommentare gibt...
Das bestimmt nicht.
Falls es da Kommentare gibt...
Okay.
Die Kommentare sind auf...
Okay, der Source-Code ist auf Englisch.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
So, dann gucken wir noch mal.
Also, was trendet denn diese Woche bei...
Bei Kobol?
Die übliche Geschichte, okay, immer das gleiche
Also was trennt er denn?
Fangen wir heute mal mit Rust an
Was trennt er denn Spannendes in Rust?
Das hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon
Hatten wir das letzte Mal auch schon
In-Process-SQL-Database
Kompatibel mit SQLite
Das ist quasi, wenn man kein SQLite-File erstellen will
Sondern in Memory
Aber warum kann man dann nicht einfach
SQLite in Memory verwenden?
Das geht doch auch
Na gut, scheint ja schon Sinn zu machen für einige.
Nur so ein Fire-Ship in seinem Video.
Ah ja, Fire-Ship haben wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt, ja.
Können wir uns angucken.
Das ist KI-Gedöns.
Allein schon dieser Text
Open Source Dark Software Factory
for Expert Engineers.
What the fuck soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Erinnert mich gleich nochmal an...
Wir können das mal aufmachen.
Fire Ship.
SQL Rust Rewrite.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Was?
Ja.
Hardware-Rad.
Trended.
Wir können mal gucken, ob wir es umgehen können.
Fire Ship.
So, Rust Rewrite.
Früher konnte man irgendwie im Bett oder so dranhängen.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es funktioniert.
War das so?
War das...
Ja.
Peckle war es bestimmt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Irgendwie konnte man Embedded an die Videos dranhängen.
Oder hier Embed, so.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das ging.
Da konnte man manchmal diese Sache umgehen.
Schau mal, wie sieht es denn hier aus?
Okay.
Jetzt erleben wir mal VLC.
Vielleicht kann es VLC direkt abspielen.
Wenn nicht, haben wir YouTube-DLP.
Da ist nix NSFW dran.
Das ist ein FireShip-Video.
Äh.
Hallo?
Wow, what the fuck?
Ah, vielleicht soll ich mal.
Leute, wir haben heute noch kein Update gemacht
Und noch kein
Was?
Warum habe ich das überhaupt installiert?
Ich brauche keine Texterkennung
Ah ne, das ist eine Dependency
Das ist eine Dependency
Eine Dependency für was?
weiß ich irgendwas hat jetzt texterkennung als die pendency
ja wir können wir können ob das mal aus daumen wir können mal voll c
installieren und mal gucken ob es abspielen ansonsten youtube dlp
Texterkennung Supply Chain Angriff.
Ja. F.
Ist Auer eigentlich immer noch kaputt?
Ich glaube mittlerweile hat sich das erledigt.
Ich habe lange nichts mehr drüber gehört jetzt.
Aber wir sollten vielleicht immer noch nicht upgraden.
Müsste ich mal gucken, aber ich glaube, es hat sich erledigt.
Auf, mach hinne.
Übrigens, eine Sache, die ich schon immer toll fand bei Arch, die Lungs, wie schnell Package-Updates und Package-Installationen und sowas gehen.
bei also gerade bei älteren rpm basierten distributionen wenn wir jetzt
gerade mal beim abdecken der repros gewesen
das wird an allen ecken passieren ja passiert ja auch an allen ecken
supply chain mein notepad plus plus ja an allen ecken passiert das sehen
versuche ich wenn ich sachen entwickelt das nur noch in containern zu machen
dass wenn ich mir mal irgendein manipuliertes Package einfange,
es sich in Grenzen hält.
Okay.
Das geht nicht.
Äh, YouTube DLP?
DLP?
Was spricht gegen ein Konjo mit automatischem Updaten?
Dass ich da nicht mehr von Hand eintippen kann.
Und nicht mehr von Hand
Rebooten.
YouTube DLP?
Ey, ja, ich quote es ja schon.
Fuck.
Man kann das nicht mehr umgehen.
Man kann es nicht mehr umgehen, ohne sich einzuloggen.
Ja, das ist ja richtiger krasser Sack, Alter.
Ja, man kann die Sperre anscheinend nicht mehr easy umgehen.
Ganz früher konnte man noch Embedded oder sowas dran schreiben.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel...
Nehmen wir mal ein Video von mir.
Da konnte man, glaube ich, früher hier einfach Embedder vorschreiben.
Und dann...
Irgendwie so ging das.
M-Bed vielleicht?
Nee.
M-Bed war das.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
ob das mal wieder die richtige
Syntax für ist.
Ich bilde mir ein,
früher konnte man das so machen.
Aber das geht dann nicht mehr.
Ja, es funzt leider nicht mehr.
Und das hat dann...
Das hat dann funktioniert.
Ja, guck. Video-ID soll man appenden.
Das hat dann funktioniert, aber das funktioniert anscheinend nicht mehr.
Das heißt, wir sind ziemlich aufgeschmissen.
Wir können das nicht mehr umgehen und dementsprechend das Video nicht gucken.
Ups.
Tja.
Recht gehabt, würde ich sagen.
Seltsam.
Gut, aber wir gucken uns erst mal die GitHub-Trends fertig an.
Also hier habe ich keinen blassen Schirm,
aber was ist das?
AI-Coding-Engine.
Okay, geh weg.
Das kennen wir schon.
Rust-Native-Trading-Engine.
Boah.
Dongs!
Das ist doch ein KI-Bild, oder?
Das sieht so typisch KI aus
Weil es auch so ein Bild ist
Was einem absolut nichts bringt
Es ist auf Pornhub
Seriously, das neue FireShip Video ist auf Pornhub
Sehe ich das richtig?
Was ist denn in diesem Video drin?
Das können wir uns vielleicht doch nicht im Stream angucken
Ja, aber ich mache kein Pornhub-Video hier im Stream auf.
Wer weiß, was da noch sonst wie eingeblendet wird.
Jedes Video von ihm ist auf Pornhub, okay.
Rauch mich.
gibt diverse leute die den porno bekam als backup haben ist das wirklich so
wird es wird auch zeit für für max fps backup
Ich mein, Tanzverbot hatte ja auch mal
einen Pornhub-Account.
Frag mich bitte nicht, woher ich das weiß.
Was sie alles gibt so also weiter das kennen wir das kennen wir kennen wir
Kai den
Universal android die plotter next generation aller was ein projekt name
Handy extra speech tipps roll down gpu
Component
Okay.
Ah, das haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Influx-DB. Ha!
Ah, lange nichts davon gehört.
23 Sterne die Woche.
Helix-DB.
AI. Okay.
Dann, Leute, jetzt...
Jetzt wird's eklig.
Ich verspreche euch auch, wir gehen schnell durch.
Was trennt denn bei C++?
Hast du vom SQLite Rewrite in Rust gehört?
Ja, wir haben ihn sogar in den Trends gefunden eben.
Und da wollten wir uns das FireShip Video angucken.
Wir haben festgestellt, es ist ab 18 und ich kann es im Stream nicht gucken.
äh
lightweight
lightning fast
in process vector
database, ok, das ist irgendwas
für KI
unreal cloud
imgui, das kenn ich tatsächlich
noch
Das gibt's auch schon ewig.
Bitcoin trendet.
Beziehungsweise die Bitcoin-Node-Software trendet.
BitTorrent! Das ist klar, das muss trenden.
Wo soll ich sonst meine Linux-Distribution runterladen?
Wasm!
WebAssembly-Runtime.
Google-Test.
Das klingt nach einem World of Warcraft Server.
Das wird Blizzard nicht gefallen, aber Blizzard kann nichts dagegen machen.
Weil solange die keine Assets und geistiges Eigentum von Blizzard verwenden,
darf jeder einen WoW-Emulator bauen.
Ceph trendet.
Das hatten wir auch mal eine Weile auf der alten Arbeit als Testaufbau.
CephFS.
SPD-Log.
Logging Library, okay
Hab ich sogar schon mal ausprobiert
Die hat
Die hat dieses
FMT-Liblogging mit dabei
AI
AI, ne
Was?
Okay, das ist wieder so ein C++-Projekt
Wo ich allein schon anhand der
Beschreibung absolut nicht checke
Was es sein soll
TTNN Operator Library
And TT Metallium Low Level
Kernel Programming Model
Was?
Im Chat gibt es jemanden von euch, der das liest und sagt...
Ah!
Classic.
Classic TTNNN Operator Library.
Ist das KI?
Das ist bestimmt KI, hä?
Token, ja, ja. Ich sehe da schon irgendwas mit Token.
MLX?
Elektron.
Wir werden es nie loswerden.
Und das auch aus gutem Grund.
Ach ja, guck mal, die Grills sind am Start.
Wir entwickeln hier mit...
Elektronen.
Ich verstehe ja, dass Elektronen so beliebt ist.
tauri größer elektron change moment
ich glaube ich kann dein mainz changen
Du musst mich nur mal auf den aktuellen Stand bringen
Ist es bei Tauri immer noch so
Dass Tauri den jeweiligen
Betriebssystem WebView verwendet
Anstatt einen gebandelten Browser zu haben
Oder nicht
Ist das nicht gerade der Vorteil
Ich hab ja noch weder Nachteil
noch Vorteil gesehen, ich will jetzt erstmal nur wissen, ist das so
Hab ich das richtig im Kopf, ja
Dass Taori den Web
den Webview von der jeweiligen Plattform
benutzt, anstatt es in Chrome zu bundeln
Das ist für mich tatsächlich
Ja, das ist ein Vorteil und ein Nachteil
weil es gibt unter linux keinen standard webview es gibt unter linux das was meistens meistens
verwendet wird dafür ist libwebkit aber libwebkit ist teilweise so hoffnungslos outdated und
schrottig da muss man sich wirklich fragt wenn man das verwenden ja man kann argumentieren auch
eine Elektron-Anwendung hat
Outdated Browser.
Das ist schon richtig.
Aber die kannst du einfacher aktualisieren.
Musst halt eine neue
Elektron-Version verwenden.
Vielleicht könnt ihr mich auch eines
besseren belehren und das ist überhaupt alles gar nicht
so. Aber deswegen finde ich
eigentlich gerade für Linux-Anwendungen
Tauri nicht so nice.
Ich find's gut, wenn eine Anwendung
Self-Contained sein kann.
dass alles dabei ist, was du brauchst.
Tauri ist written in Rust,
daher muss es besser sein. Logisch.
Da sind wir uns ja einig.
Alles, was written in Rust ist, ist besser,
weil Placingly fast.
so was half bastion text sharpening engine react native doc test stable diffusion folly
atmosphäre also custom firmware für die nintendo switch dann gucken wir noch mal was trendet bei
go das geht schnell das ist meistens sehr unspektakulär und auf linux bundle ich chromium
selbst, weil Media einfach
sonst nicht geht. Ja, okay, verstehe ich.
Wenn das easy möglich ist, dann ist
es natürlich tatsächlich ein Vorteil.
Dann kannst du Bills shippen für Windows,
Mac, iOS, Android, die den jeweiligen
Native Webview der Plattform verwenden
und für Linux bringst du Chromium mit.
Wenn das easy geht, dann hat sich das
eigentlich erledigt, was ich gesagt habe. Dann kannst du
das trotzdem machen.
Das finde ich eigentlich ein guter Kompromiss.
Das Schöne bei Elektron ist ja, dass der auf allen Plattformen einen gebandelten Chromium verwendet.
Und der rendert mehr oder weniger auf allen Plattformen gleich.
Das ist ja auch ein Grund, warum Elektron so beliebt ist.
Du musst dich nicht mit den jeweiligen Native UI Sachen rumschlagen, sondern hast im Endeffekt einen Browser ohne Browserfenster.
War Taori gegebenenfalls nicht? Das könnte natürlich sein, ja. Wobei man halt sagen muss, ich glaube das größte Problem ist an der Stelle tatsächlich wieder iOS.
oder Mac und iOS,
weil unter Windows
ist der WebView wahrscheinlich
WebView 2, das ist Edge-based, also
Chrome.
Unter Android ist es Chrome.
Unter Linux ist es in dem Fall auch
Chrome. Nur unter
Mac und iOS ist es dann halt Safari.
Da könnte es dann
vielleicht ein paar Probleme geben.
Aber immerhin, guck mal, ich meine, es ist ja
schon mal ganz nice. Guck dir mal hier.
In dem
Fall hier. Guck mal, du hast
1, 2, 3, 4,
Betriebssysteme abgedeckt.
Und du musst eigentlich
nur zwei Browsersachen
testen. Du musst gucken, wie sieht's
in Safari aus und du musst gucken, wie sieht's
unter Chrome aus. Und wenn's beides
okay aussieht, läuft's.
Also, das ist besser
als zu Zeiten, wo
alles noch, wo Windows
noch was eigenes hatte.
Aber schön ist es tatsächlich nicht.
Ich finde aber cool, dass es bei Tauri geht mit dem Bundle von Chrome.
So, Chat-Game.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch die...
Schauen wir uns schnell die Trends bei Go an und dann gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an.
So ein Ding hatte ich auch.
Für Nintendo DS.
Zwar kein F4, aber sowas ähnliches.
Natürlich nur für Homebrew Custom Sachen.
Nicht für offizielle Spiele, logisch.
So, also was der...
AI...
Nee, irgendwas anderes.
Juckt mich nicht.
AI.
Silium, das ist im Cloud-Umfeld
ganz furchtbar beliebt.
Async Q.
Simple, reliable, efficient,
distributed task, Q in go.
Oh ja.
Zeig mal, gibt es ein Example?
die go syntax ist halt wirklich die schönste war hier jedes mal aber trotzdem ist eine super
sprache oder agent kontinuierung stellt kubernetes installer stellt so eine template engine medias
server lama ei ei waschheit restig backup stellt go geht's wenn man auf die treppos
zugreifen will mit goals nicht verkehrt solche solche leibniz immer sehr praktisch
Olaris.
Haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Gitti. Auch nice.
Schon ewig installiert.
Wenn ich jetzt neu installieren würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich
Orgio verwenden.
Google Maps Scraper.
Netz H.
Das haben wir uns glaube ich schon mal
angeguckt.
Netdata.
Warum auch immer das was mit AI zu tun hat.
Kein Schimmer.
AI und NetBird.
Gut, dann als letztes.
Was trendet denn in C-Sharp?
Nicht so viel AI bei Go.
Ja, mit Go wird halt auch wirklich was geschafft.
ASP.NET Core.
CS2 Bot Improver.
Ach so.
Ah, es ist kein...
Okay, ich dachte erst, das ist ein Cheat.
Es macht die Bots besser,
gegen die du spielen kannst.
hatten wir schon hatten wir schon hatten wir schon youtube downloader
es ist hier red alert als open source engine radare für linux distribution wieder beispiel
anwendungen
er hat mir ein alter für anstiegs warte mal ist das telefon klopft
heute heute die die katz die unsere unsere besucher katz ist am start ich muss mal kurz
Ich muss mal kurz runter zur Katz.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Gucken, was sie will.
Ich bin nicht wirklich auf Klo, aber so dass man was sieht.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
wieder am start einmal ohne katze streichel muss jetzt muss jetzt sein
Also wie gesagt, ich war nicht auf dem Klo.
Brings MacOS Quick Look Feature
von Windows. Aha.
Avalonia trendet zu Recht.
Das wollte ich mir auch mal wieder angucken.
Quick Look.
Was bin ich sehend? Was ist das?
Also was sehe ich hier gerade?
Ich sehe Desktop, Last Body Fight.
Und will ich das sehen? Interessiert mich das?
Ich mag Avalonia an sich vom Projekt her.
Was ich nicht mag, ist diese ganze Xamel-Geschichte.
Das sackt einfach nur richtig hart.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Irgendwelche tollen Features, die verstehe ich nicht, was das sein soll.
So was wie das Preview beim Mac
Mit Leertaste Filevorschau
Okay, aber dann hätten sie mal einen ordentlichen Screenshot
Machen sollen, wo man auch was
Sinnvolles erkennt, außer Desktop
Desktop-Ordner
Was will ich mir quick-viewen lassen, wenn der Desktop-Ordner
Das letzte Mal modified wurde
Ah ja
Jetzt würde ich sagen, gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an
und übrigens chat sellout time guckt mal mir auf den channel in die beschreibung da werdet
ihr feststellen es gibt jetzt hier einen link mehr speicher mehr sicherheit wenn ihr darauf
klickt ihr könnt übrigens auch im chat ausrufezeichen ukraine ausrufezeichen seagate ausrufezeichen
alternate machen da kriegt ihr den link den es nur bei mir gibt da steht nämlich auch wobblors
in dem link hier guckt euch an seagate ukraine wobblors wenn ihr das aufmacht kommt ihr in einem
custom alternate shop raus die preise gelten wie gesagt nur über den link hier und da kriegt ihr
relativ günstig festplatten und ukrain aus natürlich am besten in kombination ihr habt ihr
habt ihr die auswahl zwischen zwei einsteiger nassus das dh 2300 das ist arm based und das
dxp 2008 oder das ist x86 based.
Da kriegt ihr das Ganze gleich
gebundelt mit zwei Festplatten und allem
zusammen dabei.
Sehr nice.
Als Einstiegsgerät ist das
vollkommen okay.
Und auch noch energiesparend.
Wobei ich ja persönlich eher
zu dem hier tendieren würde.
weil x86 und die cpu hat crypto extensions und 2,5 gig das hier stimmt übrigens nicht
es hat ein 2,5 gigabit port sagt die hersteller webseite und ihr kriegt damit wahrscheinlich
also ich habe es nicht ausprobiert aber es müsste ausreichen ihr kriegt damit 2,5 gig
inklusive verschlüsselung ausgelastet dadurch dass die cpu crypto extensions hat
Ansonsten ist das an sich ja relativ easy
Einfach anklicken, zack
Warenkorb
Achso, ja
Zack, zack, Warenkorb, bam
Und bestellen
So sieht es aus
Und wie gesagt, das gilt nur noch diesen Monat
Und auch nur über meinen Link
So, Sellout Ende
Das muss ich mir jetzt erstmal aufschreiben
Sellout
bei 1 Stunde
am 21.06.
aufwachen streamen.
Die wollen garantiert
irgendwie Reports danach haben.
Erfahrung
Euclidus vs. Synology
Ich glaube, ich möchte Synology.
Ja, gut. Also,
meine Meinung zu Synology ist,
uralte Hardware zu teuren Preisen.
Was Synology tatsächlich hervorhebt ist,
dass sie ein jahrelang getestetes Softwarepaket haben,
was so andere Hersteller nicht bieten können.
Es gibt die Möglichkeit, die Synology Software
auf Nicht-Synology Geräten zu installieren.
Das ist allerdings unsupported und wie gut das funktioniert,
kann ich persönlich nicht sagen.
Also es gibt ein Projekt, das nennt sich Xpenology oder so auf GitHub, irgendwie so.
Genau, das da.
Das ist quasi ein Custom Variante oder so.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Bootloader für Synology Geräte, um es auf Nicht-Synology Geräten laufen lassen zu können.
was ist die sache die software das ding hier ist es ein ology oester oder hier
diese oberfläche hast du hast ja auch ein paar kleinen anwendungen was und
notiz app client anwendungen kalender und gedöns hast ja einige klein an wenn
dieses software paket wobei ich da halt nicht weiß wie gut das auf nichts
erneut die hardware das habe ich nie ausprobiert wirklich läuft und du hast
absolut kein support und nix also es könnte auch jederzeit kaputt gehen das
ist jetzt sicherlich nicht so stable wie wenn du dir einen db an oder einen
android oder einen box oder ob media war irgendwie sowas drauf haust
Also wie gesagt, ich denke Synology hat halt alte Hardware zu ziemlich teuren Preisen, gute Software.
Ugreen ist das Gegenteil.
Ugreen hat relativ neue Hardware zu günstigen Preisen,
davon nur nicht ganz so ausgereifte Software,
was aber nicht schlimm ist, weil du kannst einfach drauf installieren, was du willst.
Und insofern, ich persönlich würde, ohne dass ich jetzt hier gesponsert bin gerade,
zum Ugreen greifen oder zu einem Minisforum,
nass, wobei Minisforum halt
nicht dafür bekannt ist, ihre
Hardware sonderlich lange zu supporten.
Die hauen die Hardware raus und dann gibt es vielleicht ein, zwei
BIOS-Updates für die schlimmsten Sachen und dann
nie wieder was von gehört.
Vom Gesamtpaket
ist, also rein von der
verbauten Hardware, von den Specs
her, finde ich das
aktuelle Minisforum
N5 heißt das glaube ich,
N5R, ganz gut.
Da ist ein PCI-Express-Slot.
NVMe Slots und sowas
besser, aber
von der verbauten Hardware,
so zum Beispiel auch von der Netzwerkkarte,
sind die U-Creen Dinger besser.
Ja, weil diese
Aquantia oder wie das heißt,
Netzwerkkarte im U-Creen ist halt deutlich besser
supported unter Linux, als die neue
Realtek Netzwerkkarte von dem Minisforum.
Hardware-Rat hört auf.
Hab ich gehört. Hab ich gestern schon gesehen.
Äh.
Was?
Das wolltest du nicht copy-pasten, oder?
Also ich hab das Hardware-Rad-Video schon gesehen.
Das Hardware-Rad wohl schließt.
In einem Monat.
Warum?
Dazu hat er noch nichts gesagt.
Da hat er gesagt,
mach da mal ein paar Videos in Zukunft zu.
Warum, weiß man nicht.
Also er ist nicht pleite, das hat er auch gesagt.
Ja, Shorts ist
Pain's Champ.
Gut.
Listening, Leute.
Ach, deswegen ist es ab 18.
Ach, geil.
YouTube.
So.
Was gucken wir uns denn mal an?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Zorin OS im Test.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Juckt mich nicht.
Kaif brisst die Cloud.
Warum Hetzner
erst der Anfang ist.
Okay, das können wir uns tatsächlich angucken.
Finde ich ein ganz interessantes Thema.
Ist auch noch 7,55 lang.
Das gucken wir uns mal an.
Die Hetzner Preise haben wir uns ja schon gestern angeguckt.
Und die wurden, sind teilweise
saftig hochgegangen.
Von 15,99 auf 42,99 Euro.
Also die Hetzner Preise
sind also nicht in allem ja aber in einigen breiten die richtig krass hoch
gegangen
jetzt halt mal den namen nicht kennt das ist ein
deutscher haus hetzner bei den namen nicht kennt das ist ein deutscher
hausnummer aus gunzenhausen in bayern sehr beliebt bei entwicklern bei
freelancern bei kleinen unternehmen der ruf günstig zuverlässig unkompliziert
Ja, so ein bisschen das IKEA der deutschen Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Diese Woche sind bei Hetzner neue Preise in Kraft getreten und die haben für Aufregung und Diskussionen gesorgt.
Bei Cloud-Servern steigen die Preise je nach Instanz deutlich.
Rechnet man die neuen Hetzner Cloud-Preise ungewichtet über die betroffenen Tarife,
kommt man in Deutschland und Finnland auf rund plus 99 Prozent.
In den USA sind es sogar um die 158 Prozent plus.
Einzelne Instanzen kosten künftig sogar ungefähr das Dreifache.
Und die Begründung von Hetzner ist bemerkenswert. Die Beschaffungskosten für Hardware seien massiv gestiegen. Besonders RAM, SSDs und GPUs seien schwer kalkulierbar. Der Auslöser dahinter? Die Nachfrage nach KI-Infrastruktur.
Jetzt könnte man sagen, na und? Ich habe keinen Server bei Hetzner, betrifft mich nicht.
Doch das wäre zu kurz gedacht, denn Hetzner ist nicht nur ein einzelner Hosting-Anbieter.
Hetzner ist in diesem Fall ein Signal, ein Frühwarnsystem dafür, dass der KI-Boom nicht nur Rechenzentren betrifft,
sondern die Preise für ganz normale IT-Hardware verschiebt.
In den nächsten Minuten geht es darum, was hinter dieser Preiserhöhung steckt,
warum dasselbe Problem auch Smartphones teurer machen kann
und warum langfristig auch Cloud-Speicherabos unter Kostendruck geraten könnten.
Die neuen Preise gelten seit dem 15. Juni.
Betroffen sind Neubestellungen und sogenannte Rescales.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was mit meinem 1-Euro-Server bei IONOS passiert.
Ich habe da vor zig Jahren mal so einen 1-Euro-Server abgeschlossen.
Hauptsächlich, weil es eine statische IPv4-Adresse gab.
und der kostet regelmäßig jeden Monat aktuell immer noch 99 Cent oder einen Euro halt.
Ich glaube einen Euro, nicht 99 Cent, einen Euro.
Bin mal gespannt, was die damit machen.
... die Cloud-Instanz verändert, zum Beispiel mehr RAM oder mehr CPU braucht.
Wer seinen bestehenden Server einfach so weiterlaufen lässt, der zahlt vorerst noch den alten Preis.
Das ist die gute Nachricht für Bestandskunden.
Macht der aktuell irgendwas? Nö.
Aber wer neu bestellt oder die Instanz verändert, der landet im neuen Tarif.
Ein Beispiel, der Cloud-Server CPX42 in Deutschland und Finnland kostet jetzt 82,69 Euro im Monat, statt vorher 30,33 Euro.
In den USA steigt der CPX 41 von 46,40 auf 143,38 Euro.
Ich habe gestern was gesehen, das ist von 15 Euro auf 42 Euro gestiegen.
Ist auch heftig.
100. Das ist mehr als eine Verdreifachung.
Aber warum passiert das gerade jetzt? Und warum ausgerechnet wegen KI?
Die Antwort liegt in einem Bauteil, das die meisten von euch nie zu Gesicht bekommen.
Das aber in fast jedem modernen Gerät steckt.
Speicher, Arbeitsspeicher, also RAM.
Also, wir haben die schon öfters mal zu Gesicht bekommen.
Und Flashspeicher, also NAND.
Aber Chat, Chat, leider hat mein RAM ja Mikrorisse.
Hat der Chat zumindest gesagt.
Das Mainboard, der RAM, die Grafiker haben alle Mikrorisse.
Warum habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden, aber wenn der Chat das sagt, dann muss das so sein.
Mehr dazu gleich nach einer kurzen Werbepause.
Dieses Video wird präsentiert von EM-Client, einem Europäischen...
Die gibt's noch? Das habe ich mal für ein halbes Jahr oder so verwendet.
Das gibt's noch?
...Page-Mail-Programm und Produktivitätstool für Windows, Mac, Android und iOS.
Was EM-Client besonders macht, alle Postfächer laufen in einem gemeinsamen Posteingang zusammen.
Das Wechseln zwischen Konten entfällt.
Egal ob Textbausteine per Kürzel einfügen, wiederkehrende Schritte automatisieren,
Mails mit einem Klick in den richtigen Ordner schieben.
EM-Client ist klar auf Effizienz ausgelegt.
Übersetzungen funktionieren direkt in der App und wer möchte,
kann sich beim Schreiben und Beantworten von Mails von KI unterstützen lassen.
Datenschutzfreundlich, ohne dass Inhalte gespeichert werden.
Wenn ihr eure E-Mails deutlich besser bearbeiten wollt, probiert doch mal EM-Client aus.
Den Link findet ihr in der Beschreibung und mit dem Code HEISEN...
By the way, ich bin mittlerweile wieder bei Thunderbird und bleib da auch.
... bis 20% Rabatt für 6 Wochen.
Diese Speicherchips werden gerade deutlich teurer.
Moment, für sechs Wochen? Moment, das gibt da mittlerweile ein Abo?
Nicht nur, weil Serveranbieter mehr davon brauchen, sondern weil KI-Rechenzentren enorme Mengen Speicher binden.
Wer moderne KI-Modelle trainiert oder betreibt, der braucht GPUs, also Grafikprozessoren von Nvidia, AMD oder anderen Anbietern.
Diese GPUs brauchen wiederum besonders schnellen Speicher.
HBM, High Bandwidth Memory.
Der Markt dafür ist extrem konzentriert. Samsung, SK Hynix und Micron dominieren den Speicherbereich und sind auch die zentralen Anbieter für HBM.
Und HBM für KI-Beschleuniger ist für die Hersteller deutlich attraktiver als normale Arbeitsspeicher für Server, Laptops oder Smartphones.
Die Folge? Produktionskapazitäten wandern dorthin, wo die Margen hoch sind, also Richtung KI-Hardware.
Für andere Bereiche, klassische Server, PCs, Laptops, Smartphones, wird Speicher knapper oder teurer.
Und genau das landet jetzt in den Preislisten.
Der Chef des französischen Cloud-Anbieters OVHcloud, Octave Clabat, hatte schon vor Monaten davor gewarnt,
dass neue Server durch steigende Speicherpreise deutlich teurer werden könnten.
Bei Hetzner sehen wir jetzt, wie stark so etwas im Endkundenpreis ankommen kann.
Wichtig ist aber, das ist nicht eins zu eins vergleichbar.
Hardware-Beschaffungskosten sind nicht dasselbe wie Mietpreise für Cloud-Server.
In den Endkundenpreis fließen auch Strom, Standortkosten, Abschreibung, Auslastung und Geschäftsstrategie ein.
Trotzdem zeigt die Hetzner-Erhöhung, wie heftig der Druck auf die Infrastrukturbranche geworden ist.
Jetzt kommt der Teil, der für alle relevant ist, auch für die, die noch nie von Hetzner gehört haben.
Dieselben Speicherchips, die Server teurer machen, stecken auch in Smartphones, Laptops und PCs.
Und auch dort kommt der Preis.
Und Konsolen.
Ist Druck an. IDC erwartet für 2026 einen deutlichen Rückgang der Smartphone-Auslieferungen. Vor allem wegen der Speicherkrise. Gleichzeitig soll der durchschnittliche Verkaufspreis von Smartphones um rund 14% steigen.
Da muss ich mal überlegen, das ursprüngliche...
Wie hieß das Ding? Steam Deck, ne?
Ja, Steam Deck.
Das ist sogar wieder im Preis gestiegen, obwohl es eine uralte Kiste ist.
Besonders hart trifft das den unteren Preisbereich.
Wenn RAM und Flash teurer werden, geraten günstige Android-Geräte besonders unter Druck.
Hersteller haben dann im Grunde drei Möglichkeiten.
Sie erhöhen die Preise, sie reduzieren die Ausstattung oder sie streichen bestimmte günstige Modelle ganz.
Und dann ist dann noch die Frage, was ist mit iCloud, Google One, OneDrive und anderen Cloud-Speichern?
Hier muss man aktuell klar sagen, konkrete neue Preiserhöhungen wegen der Speicherkrise sind bei den großen Consumer-Cloud-Diensten bislang nicht in Sicht.
Apple, Google und Microsoft haben dazu keine klare Ansage gemacht.
Aber auch diese Anbieter kaufen Speicher und werden Rechenzentren und müssen Hardware ersetzen.
Wenn RAM, SSDs und Server dauerhaft teurer bleiben.
Also ich habe gehört bei uns auf der Arbeit, dass teilweise bei HP und Dell und sowas, also ich weiß nicht, was wir da für Serveranbieter jetzt aktuell gerade haben, dass da teilweise die Serverpreise um das Dreifache gestiegen sind.
In manchen Fällen sogar um das Zehnfache.
Also wahrscheinlich bei irgendwelchen spezialisierten Dingern.
Das Zehnfache.
Das ist krass, oder?
erhöht das langfristig den Kostendruck.
Ob und wann das bei privaten Cloud-Abos ankommt, ist offen.
Aber der Druck auf die Kostenbasis, der ist definitiv da.
Was bedeutet das konkret?
Wenn ihr Hetzner-Kunden seid, Ruhe bewahren und die eigene Konfiguration prüfen.
Bestehende Cloud-Instanzen, die ihr nicht verändert, bleiben vorerst im alten Tarif.
Aber wenn ihr neue Server plant oder bestehende Instanzen rescalen wollt,
solltet ihr die neuen Preise genau durchrechnen.
Alternativen wie NetCap oder andere Anbieter kann man prüfen,
Aber man sollte nicht erwarten, dass alle anderen dauerhaft verschont bleiben.
Der Speichermarkt betrifft die ganze Branche.
Nur reagieren Anbieter unterschiedlich schnell und unterschiedlich stark.
Wenn ihr gerade ein neues Smartphone kaufen wollt, die Speicherkrise ist tatsächlich ein Argument,
nicht ewig auf fallende Preise zu warten.
Das heißt nicht, dass jedes Modell sofort teurer wird.
Aber die Marktforscher sehen klar steigenden Druck auf Preise und Ausstattung.
Und für alle, die Cloud-Speicher nutzen, jetzt ist ein guter Moment, den eigenen Verbrauch zu überprüfen.
Braucht ihr wirklich den gebuchten Tarif? Liegen dort alte Backups, doppelte Fotos oder Daten?
Naja, ich habe einen 2TB OneDrive, weil es in der Office 365 Abo drin ist.
Und Chat, ich weiß, ich benutze es nicht oft, ich bin kein Fan von Office, aber ich habe es trotzdem, hauptsächlich wegen den 2TB.
...lokal archivieren könnt?
Ansonsten benutze ich von den Office-Programmen so gut wie gar nichts.
ich habe es schon oft gesagt, also
ich benutze weder Word noch Excel noch sonst was.
Das Einzige, was ich ab und zu mal verwende, ist PowerPoint.
Und dann auch nur,
wenn das halt,
also auf der Arbeit,
privat mache ich jetzt keine Presentations oder so.
Und dann auch nur,
weil die halt auf der Arbeit drauf stehen, wenn das die
Präsentation im Corporate Design ist.
Ein NAS kann für manche
eine Alternative sein, aber nicht
für alle. Es kostet einmalig Geld, braucht
Pflege, Strom, Backups und ein
bisschen technisches Verständnis. Für Familienfotos, große Archive oder lokale Backups kann es sinnvoll
sein. Für viele bleibt Cloud-Speicher trotzdem bequemer. Und was lernen wir daraus? Hetzner ist
nicht das Problem. Hetzner hat nur sehr sichtbar gemacht. Das habe ich auch gestern ja gesagt. Ich
habe gestern ja auch klar gesagt, ich denke auch nicht, dass Hetzner es einfach mal danach ist oder
so. Denen bleibt einfach nichts anderes übrig. Was in der Branche schon länger diskutiert wird.
KI verändert nicht nur, wie wir arbeiten, KI verändert auch, welche Hardware knapp wird und was diese Hardware kostet. Diese Kosten können mit Verzögerungen bei uns allen ankommen. Als teurere Server, als teurere Smartphones, als schlechter ausgestattete Einsteigergeräte oder irgendwann auch als höhere Preise für digitale Dienste.
Das ist keine Panikmache.
Das wird früher oder später natürlich dann auch passieren.
Es werden ja noch mehr Anbieter versuchen, ein Abo aufs Auge zu drücken und das auch
noch mehr Anbieter die Preise erhöhen.
Klar.
Aber es ist ein Warnsignal.
Wenn euch diese Art von Einordnung weiterhilft, dann freuen wir uns über ein Abo dieses Kanals
und wenn das Video interessant war, gebt doch gerne ein Like.
Wir behalten das ganze Thema natürlich für euch im Blick, ständig hier auf dem Kanal.
Excellent.
Und ich sehe es aktuell auch nicht, dass das irgendwie runter geht.
Letztendlich wird das wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit nur runter gehen, sollte der Fall eintreten, dass KI-Sachen quasi gesättigt sind.
Aber das sehe ich nicht.
Also sprich, dass die Leute sagen, boah, nee, mehr KI brauche ich dann nicht mehr oder so.
Oder, oder, äh, braucht die neuesten Modelle nicht.
Also, dass so eine Sättigung bei KI eintritt, so, das wird vielleicht was bringen.
Aber das glaube ich nicht.
Ja.
Wenn die das in der Form erwartet hätten
Und es sich für sie gelohnt hätte
Dann hätten die das auch gemacht
Warum sollten die das nicht machen?
Die sagen ja nicht, ich will kein Geld verdienen
Ja, es kann sich, das ist auch möglich
Wenn KI so teuer ist
Habe ich doch letztens in irgendeinem News-Beitrag sogar gelesen, dass einige IT-Unternehmen jetzt gesagt haben,
KI ist uns mittlerweile zu teuer, da können wir ja sogar Menschen für einstellen.
Können wir Menschen für einstellen, die billiger sind, als was wir für KI ausgeben.
Aber ihr wisst ja, Tokens gleich Profit.
Wenn es der Nvidia-Chef sagt, dann ist es so.
Was haben wir hier noch?
Tierarzt an der Grenzkontrolle.
Aha, das war was Interessantes.
Es pendelt sich immer da ein, wo es für die Hersteller am besten ist.
Oder wo sie denken, dass es am besten ist.
Und wenn die die Produktion erhöhen könnten, so easy mal kurz.
dann hätten sie das auch gemacht sofern sich lohnt macht macht ja keinen sinn
für die zu sagen ich glaube kein geld verdienen
Er hat viel gesagt, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Wie gesagt, Tokens, Tokens sind Profit.
Und was hat er auch noch erzählt?
Das...
Wie war das?
dass ein...
ein...
dass ein Entwickler,
dem man 140.000 Euro
oder irgendwie oder 200.000 Euro
im Jahr bezahlt,
kein guter Entwickler ist,
wenn er nicht mindestens nochmal
200.000 in Tokens ausgibt?
War das nicht so? Irgendwie sowas in der Rechnung
hat er doch erzählt.
So nach dem Motto,
guter Entwickler kostet 200.000 und gibt nochmal
200.000 für Tokens aus. Nur dann ist er ein guter Entwickler.
Genau, und die haben auch gesagt, die Entwickler sind dann irgendwie dreimal effektiver mit Tokens.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Der ist halt im Marketing-Modus.
Was soll er denn machen?
Ganz ehrlich.
Wenn du Hardware dafür verkaufst, natürlich hypst du das weiter.
Was denn auch sonst?
Die wollen Geld verdienen.
Und am besten noch mehr Geld.
Verständlicherweise.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Tierarzt an der Grenzkontrolle.
Gehaltenschirmflug. Das finde ich immer ganz spannend.
Dann irgendwelche verrückten Leute,
die irgendeine Schlange im Koffer haben oder so.
Moment.
Sollte, sollte...
Also sollte man nicht Hardware gerade erstmal selbst zu Wort kommen lassen?
So, wir gucken uns mal an, was der Tierarzt am Flughafen München so treibt.
Warum schickt einer in einem Paket Mäuse?
Wir fahren jetzt weiter zum Terminal 2. Ich bin der Tierarzt, wir kontrollieren ja die Vögel, die an Bord sind.
Wer bist denn du?
Norman.
Ja?
Das ist nett, verbeamtet zu sein, aber die Arbeit muss einem ja Spaß machen.
Hallo, mein Name ist Henrik Tantler.
Ich bin Tierarzt an der Grenzkontrollstelle des Flughafens München.
Okay, Chat. Wir müssen mal kurz Chat lesen.
Da gab es eine lange Message gerade.
Zeig mal her.
Ja, also. Wir machen mal kurz ein bisschen noch Genudel im Hintergrund an.
Vogel!
entwurf los hat mal eine frage ich bin am ende des zweiten jahres zu fisi
ausbildung exzellent ich werde eine präsentation über die hacks aus der
serie mister robot halten welche original an welche originale sie
angelehnt sind wie sie zum teil funktionieren was es noch für 12
ist ex gibt außerdem will ich kurz stil kies demonstrieren was der hintergrund
durch die serie bin ich auch viele dinge aufmerksam geworden habe so einiges
gelernt was ist eure meinung dazu
die idee finde ich nicht schlecht das 60 also ganz ehrlich eine 60 minuten
präsentation zu füllen ist gar nicht so ohne muss halt gucken dass das spannende
bleibt.
Das geht schon. Du musst halt
gucken, dass es spannend bleibt.
Und wichtig, wichtig,
überleg dir, wer das Publikum
ist.
Also wenn wir das Publikum wären,
uns könntest du Technik-Kram erzählen,
wenn dazu helft, da auch irgendwelche
Personalleute und Managementleute sitzen.
Die interessiert jetzt wahrscheinlich
der JSON-Output von einem Curl-Request
nie so wirklich.
Aus Sicht finde ich die Idee nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es für die EAK ist.
das wird bei ihm auf der Arbeit sein.
Was ich übrigens gut finde,
das ist im Prinzip
das, was ich ja gestern auch gesagt habe,
nur geile Sachen
machen auf der Arbeit,
bringt es nicht. Man muss auch ein bisschen Werbung für sich
machen und das, was man gemacht hat.
Und in dem Fall macht er ein bisschen Werbung für sich.
Die Leute kennen ihn danach,
wenn es eine gute Präsi ist.
Auch positiv mit ihm verknüpft, ja.
Das ist auf jeden Fall
the way für die Karriere
Grindr.
Das wäre
natürlich witzig, wenn
du mit einem schwarzen Hoodie
da auftauchst.
Und ganz wichtig,
hat jetzt zwar mit Mr. Robot
nichts zu tun,
Der muss auch sein.
Die Präsentation ist für die Schule
und ich mache die aus Eigeninteresse
Die 60 Minuten wird super leicht
Ich muss schauen, dass ich den Rahmen nicht sprenge
Da kannst du deine Presentation Skills auch üben
Das schadet auch nichts.
Guck mal weiter, was der Tierarzt treibt.
Grenzkontrollstellen, die befinden sich immer an den Außengrenzen von Europa.
Also das ist zum einen der Flughafen München, weil eben Flugzeuge aus Amerika oder aus China direkt...
China-Chinesen wieder.
...an diesen Außengrenzen werden.
Die Mäuse von AliExpress.
eben waren tierischen ursprungs und tiere kontrolliert hallo elisabeth und dann schauen
wir was wir für anmeldungen haben heute bevor wir uns jetzt das tier oder die ware anschauen
machen wir eine dokumentenkontrolle das müssen wir eben kontrollieren ist das land zugelassen
ist der betrieb zugelassen und da muss man eben gucken ob das korrekte gesundheitszeugnis
ausgesucht worden ist und die dokumente sind aus china bestimmt genauso gefakt wie die sachen von
AliExpress.
Also nicht die Sachen, ich meine nicht
die
Sachen, die man da bestellt, die gefakt
sind, aber die Dokumente sind teilweise
übelst gefakt. Die haben ja auch immer drunter
früher hingeschrieben, das kostet weniger
als 100 Euro und sowas.
Da waren ja bekannt dafür, dass die es damit
alles nicht so eng sehen,
nicht so eng nehmen.
Und gefakt sind auch viele Produkte.
Weil gerade wenn du Elektronik-Sachen
bestellst, ja und das sind ja
oftmals irgendwelche nachgebauten Dinger,
beispielsweise wenn du früher einen ESP2866
NodeMCU bestellt hattest, oder einen D1 Mini,
das waren alles immer keine Originalen, das waren einfach nachgebaute Boards,
die aber genauso gut funktioniert haben. Ja, ein paar Kleinigkeiten
ich hatten, ja, vielleicht ein paar kleine Widerstände weniger an Stellen, wo man
ein bisschen Geld sparen kann, also doch nicht hundertprozentig Äquivalenz zum Original,
aber die bauen halt gerne da Sachen nach. Aber trotzdem,
Ich habe auch schon selbst viel bei AliExpress bestellt.
Und gerade Elektronikkram ist top.
Nie Probleme mit gehabt.
Was ich auch nicht kaufen würde bei AliExpress,
sind irgendwelche Steckdosen, Verlängerungssachen,
wo 230 Volt drüber gehen.
Das nicht.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Wenn es um Sicherheitssachen geht,
oder ob irgendwas abfackelt,
das würde ich nicht machen.
Das liegt bei uns.
Und dann nach dem ersten Schritt der Dokumentenkontrolle kommt dann der zweite Schritt der Nehmlichkeitskontrolle oder Identitätskontrolle.
Und da gehen wir dann zu der Sendung hin und schauen, ob die Identität passt.
Der dritte Schritt ist dann die Warenkontrolle, wenn jetzt, wie nennen es immer, Warenkontrolle oder die Tierkontrolle, der physische Check,
dass man dann die Boxen aufmacht und guckt, wie ist das Produkt? Sind das tatsächlich Federn?
Hier haben wir jetzt die Sendung mit den Federn.
Sind das Federn oder echte Vögel?
Mal gucken, ob auch tatsächlich Federn drin sind.
Dann schaue ich mir das tatsächlich an und schaue, sind die Federn tatsächlich sauber?
Sind die Federn, sehe ich an den Federschäften noch eventuell Blut hängen?
Oder riechen die Federn so ein bisschen vergammelt oder nach Vogel?
Die Tiere und die Waren tierischen Ursprungs werden kontrolliert.
Alex fragt, warst du schon mal im Kakerlaken?
Streichelzoo.
Was für ein Ding.
Einmal zu verhindern, dass Krankheiten aus dem Ausland zu uns nach Europa kommen.
Daneben kümmern wir uns um die Lebensmittelhygiene.
Als kleiner Junge war ich immer fasziniert von Afrika,
von afrikanischen Tieren.
Ich bin dann auf eine Art Wildhüter-Schule gestoßen
oder Wildlife-Management-Schule.
Dann hab ich mich dort beworben und wurde angenommen.
Nach zwei Jahren bin ich zurück nach Europa gekommen.
Wildlife-Management, Alter, was man alles studieren kann?
habe ich mir halt überlegt, was ich dann noch studieren kann.
Und dann habe ich mich schlussendlich für Tiermedizin entschieden.
Irgendwann habe ich im Landesamt für Gesundheit und Lebensmittelsicherheit
eine Stelle in der Taskforce Infektiologie bekommen.
Und über diese Taskforce habe ich dann die Grenzkontrollstelle für Tierärzte kennengelernt.
Was alles gibt.
Von der Taskforce Infektiologie an die Grenzkontrollstelle.
So, jetzt haben wir die zweite Sendung.
Jetzt haben wir hier Mäuse.
Es hieß erst, die Mäuse kämen zur Zwischenversorgung.
Das stimmt nicht, die Mäuse kommen zur Veterinärkontrolle.
Jetzt gehen wir mal Tiere angucken.
Prinzipiell gilt, dass man bei Tieren jedes Tier kontrolliert.
Aber es gibt halt Sendungen.
Jetzt haben wir hier 60 Mäuse.
Die wuseln alle durcheinander eventuell.
Guck mal hier, da kann man die schön sehen. Hoppala, hallo kleine Mäuschen. Schau mal.
Das sind spezifisch pathogenfreie Boxen, also ich kann diese Box nicht aufmachen.
Also ich sollte das Tunlicht vermeiden, die aufzumachen.
Die haben Futter und Wasser hier drin für mehrere Tage. Die sind also gut versorgt.
Das finde ich auch wild, dass da einfach eine Box mit 60 Mäusen drin ist.
Vielleicht sogar 16, 17, 18.
Bei Sendung ab 10 Tiere müssen wir nur noch 10% anschauen.
Heute Morgen hatten wir leider keine Fische.
Aber bei tropischen Zierfischen haben wir manchmal Sendungen,
da sind 30.000 Fische.
Ich kann nicht 40 Kartons aufmachen und jeden Fisch mir anschauen.
Ich schaue mir das Tier an.
Ich sehe, ist das Tier aktiv? Ist das Tier neugierig?
Werbung, ja. Ich mache jetzt keins erlaubt.
Ist das Tier allgemein befinden?
Die kamen aus Amerika und waren für Thailand bestimmt, wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
Was in Thailand mit den Mäusen passiert ist, das wissen wir nicht.
Also wahrscheinlich möglicherweise Versuchstiere.
Was mir viel schwerer gefallen ist, mal abzufertigen, waren Haifischflossen.
Haifischflossen?
Es waren mehrere hundert Kilo oder sogar Tonnen Haifisch, getrocknete Haifischflossen,
die wir uns angucken mussten.
Und da hätte ich natürlich am liebsten gesagt, die werden jetzt gesperrt, die werden vernichtet, die werden zurückgeschickt.
Aber ich kann natürlich, ich muss mich an Gesetze halten.
Da sind uns auch die Hände gebunden. Wir müssen dann unsere Kontrolle machen hier vor Ort.
Gucken, ob die Lebensmittel...
Ich habe auch mal, wir hatten mal einen Däne auf der Arbeit.
Und er hat mal so fermentierten Haifisch mitgebracht.
Das waren so Snacks, die es irgendwie in Dänemark gibt.
Das hat mega abartig geschmeckt.
...bedingungen passen, ob die Dokumente irgendwie passen und die dann weiterfliegen lassen.
Das ist alles Paletti, jetzt müssen wir halt dann die Papiere fertig machen, dass die Kontrolle hier geklappt hat und hier alles in Ordnung war und dann dürfen die nachher dann weiterfliegen.
Hallihallo, wer bist denn du? Maria, wen haben wir denn da? Einen kleinen Hund? Aha, das ist Norman. Hallo Norman.
Hallo Norman. Na, wollen wir dich mal rauslassen?
Das gefährlichste Tier, ich vermute Hunde. Man denkt dann immer, das gefährlichste Tier ist die Klapperschlange gewesen.
Wir hatten schon Klapperschlangen hier.
Aber die Klapperschlange ist ja an sich nicht gefährlich.
Oder wenn wir Spinnen haben, wir haben so Vogelspinnen, da denkt man immer, die sind so gefährlich, die springen einem gleich an den Hals.
Wenn man die vorsichtig rausnimmt, die sind nicht aggressiv und die laufen einem dann über die Hand.
Oh, das wäre ja was für mich, ey.
Vogelspinnen über die Hand laufen lassen, Alter.
Ich glaube, das ist eines der, wahrscheinlich, ich kann mir wenig Schlimmeres vorstellen.
Ich bin nicht aggressiv, das Tier ist nicht aggressiv.
Dann gibt es gar kein so richtiges Gefahrenpotenzial.
Wir hatten mal einen Luchs, den haben wir auch mit Vorsicht behandelt.
Das Tier hatte seine Pfote beim Transport verletzt.
Wir haben hier ein bisschen Blut gesehen in der Box.
Aber man kann nicht erkennen, was mit seinen Pfoten ist.
Die funktionieren ganz gut noch, dass da ein angeht.
Denn der Luchs ist ziemlich angriffslustig.
Da wird gefaucht.
Wir müssen halt gucken, ob das...
Ah ja, guck mal, der Luchs ist wahrscheinlich mega gestresst.
Belegt euch mal, ihr wart ein Luchs, seid irgendwie vier Stunden, fünf Stunden im Flugzeug rumgeschüttelt worden.
Habt euch die Pfote verletzt.
Natürlich seid ihr da nicht gut drauf.
Hauptmöglich ist, wenn es tatsächlich auskäme, dann haben wir ein riesen, riesen, riesen, riesen Problem.
Hallo Norman.
Na, wollen wir dich mal rauslassen?
Manchmal lässt Maria den Hund raus, manchmal lassen wir den Hund raus.
Hoppala, hoppala, Norman.
Hoppala, oi, oi, oi.
Jetzt mal mal.
Ne, schau mal.
Das ist ein Chip-Lesegerät.
Jeder Hund und jede Katze.
Und verschickt man seinen Hund per Post?
Benötigt einen 15-stelligen Mikrochip.
Gucke mal.
Norman zieht aus den USA nach Deutschland.
Ah, okay.
Jetzt lauf bloß nicht aufs Vorfeld und hau ab.
Oh nein.
Norman, so ein schlechtes Wetter, wa?
Schau mal. Hoppala.
Gucke mal.
Norman will schon wieder abhauen.
Willst du schon wieder zurück?
Willst du zurückkommen?
Das ist ja wieder die Box.
liegt uns natürlich am Herzen.
Dementsprechend haben wir hier den Zwingerbereich,
wo das Tier mehr Platz hat und sich bewegen kann.
Wo es Futter und Wasser bekommt, eine Decke bekommt.
Die Tierpfleger oder wir Tierärzte gehen mit dem Tier spazieren.
Zum Glück wirst du gleich abgeholt und musst nicht weiterfliegen.
Je nachdem, wie wir zeitlich aufgestellt sind,
fahren wir immer wieder stichprobenartig aufs Vorfeld
und gucken uns dann den Transport der Tiere vom Flugzeug
bis zu uns zur Grenzkontrollstelle an.
Wir fahren jetzt weiter zum Terminal 2.
Da kommt gleich ein Flugzeug aus England.
Es gibt ja diese YATA, die Tierschutzflugtransportregeln.
Die besagen z.B., dass Tiere als Letztes
ins Flugzeug eingeladen werden sollen,
damit sie als Erstes wieder ausgeladen werden können.
Jetzt müssen wir uns ansehen.
Das klingt ja sinnig.
Was?
Aha.
Ja, das sind noch keine Vögel.
Die Vögel?
Die Vögel!
Hier sollen 14 Vögel sein.
Hier sollen Vögel sein?
Auf dem Flugzeug?
Ja, vorne.
Ah, wunderbar.
Die sind aber auch nicht nach Vögeln los.
Es sei denn, die sind im AKH drin.
Da ist nichts mehr.
Wo sind sie denn hin?
Keine Ahnung.
Oder die sind in irgendeinem Container.
Da ist momentan nichts mehr.
Entschuldigung, wissen Sie, ob hier die Vögel drin sind?
Die kommen eigentlich auf Prachthof.
Ah, okay, die kommen da.
Sind da die Vögel?
Wahrscheinlich schicken die den einfach immer nur weiter.
So, ja, frag mal da.
Frag mal da, frag mal da.
Wallah, Bruder, frag da.
Achso, ne. 13 Vögel, ja?
13 mehr.
Da sind die Vögel.
Ne.
Das ist nur Gepäck.
Sind die noch drin, die Vögel?
Oder sind die nicht geflogen?
Aber eigentlich waren die doch manifestiert, oder?
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht.
Da steht PKC-Palette drauf alles.
Aber im AKH sind die normalerweise nicht.
Das ist die andere Palette, die kleine Palette.
Ah, da sind sie.
Ja, guck, da sind sie.
Das konnte man nicht sehen im Bauch des Fliegers.
Wenn Sie schon schauen.
Super, passt alles, danke schön.
Wir wissen nicht, warum die Tiere nicht als letztes eingeladen wurden.
Wir haben das gemeldet und um eine kleine Stellungnahme gebeten.
So machen die Tiere jetzt einen schönen Eindruck.
Die haben Futter, die haben Wasser, die Boxen sind wieder richtig beschriftet.
Mit oben, mit unten, mit Live Animals, von wem die kommen und wohin die gehen.
Das ist jetzt so 8,6. Und so macht der einen guten Eindruck. Das Federkleid ist hübsch.
Schau mal an, die Flügel, ganz hübsch hier hinten mit den roten Fädern.
Bock da drauf hat der Vogel aber sicherlich nicht.
Also machen die einen guten, tollen Eindruck.
Sobalda.
Muss mal das Licht aus, bitte. Maria?
Ja?
Bin ich einmal bereit?
Ja.
Allgemein kann man Tiere durch Dunkelheit ruhig stellen,
im besonderen Vögel.
Und wir haben dann bei uns im Tierbehandlungsraum...
So Instantnacht.
Erst nach Mittag, Bäm, Instantnacht.
Das Licht ausgemacht.
Ja gut, dann muss ich jetzt schlafen, weil es ist ja dunkel, es ist Nacht.
Wenn die nichts mehr sehen, dann fliegen sie ja nicht mehr.
Kannste sehen.
Hast du ihn?
Ja.
60 285
als Beamter im höheren Dienst verdiene ich pro Monat brutto 6072 Euro dazu bekomme ich dann noch
Zulagen einmal für meine Tochter und zum anderen für den etwas teureren Wohnort hier in der Nähe
München plus andere Aufwandsentschädigungen. Am Ende des Monats habe ich dann 6.611 Euro Brutto,
wovon wir dann... Warum kriegt er für seine Tochter extra Geld? Das verstehe ich nicht.
4.805 Euro netto bleiben. Von diesen 4.805 Euro bezahle ich noch die private Krankenversicherung
und damit habe ich am Ende des Monats für mich 4.390 Euro übrig.
Geht doch klar.
Aber immerhin muss man wirklich sagen, der scheint ja auch wirklich viel zu schaffen.
So, alle Vögel, die da sein sollten, sind da.
Passt von den Nummern, von der Gesundheit passt das.
Boxen sind gut beschriftet, Tieren geht's gut.
Mein altes Auto ging nicht mehr, ich brauchte halt ein neues Auto.
Ich hab geschaut, was könnte mir gefallen.
Die Form, die Farbe, die...
Hey, was ist denn?
Guck mal hier, das Elektrische, was nicht funktioniert.
Die Bildschirme, das Digitale, das Aufgeräumte.
Kommt mal rein.
Hat ein bisschen gedauert, hier was zu finden.
Das ist ja gar nicht so einfach, wenn man wiederkommt in Bayern bzw. in der Nähe von München.
Mein Job lohnt sich nicht aufgrund des Gehaltes, sondern weil es ein toller Job ist.
Ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass ihm das gefällt, was er da macht.
... dass der auch noch wirklich gut bezahlt ist.
Hä? Was ist mit dem Logitech-Ding?
So, das war ein Arbeitstag an der Grenzkontrollstelle.
Und er hat, das sieht doch so aus, als hätte er ordentlich was zu tun.
Und dem macht sein Job Spaß.
Was zum Teufel habe ich hier wieder für komische...
Was?
Chat?
Was ist denn da los?
Sekunde.
Ich glaube, die Mikrowelle ist schon an
Um 11.35 Uhr
Was ist denn da los? Sekunde, Sekunde
Ich muss mal checken
Ich habe noch Zeit, eineinhalb Stunden
Ja, um 12 gibt es Essen.
Das ist halt viel früher als sonst.
Wanderweise kriegt es dann darum eins oder so.
Naja, machst du nix.
Essen für die Katze. Was es gibt?
Es gibt vegane Bolognese mit Pilzen.
Also nicht vegane Bolognese, das stimmt nicht.
Bolognese-Soße mit Pilzen und veganem Hackfleisch.
Ich ernähre mich ja nicht vegan
Ich futter ab und zu ganz gern mal
Vegane Produkte
Aber ich bin weder Vegetarier
Noch Veganer
Bei meinem Teambuilding Event
Hab ich auch Rindfleisch gefuttert
Ich versuch aber weniger Fleisch zu essen
Weil das gesünder ist
Das ist der hauptsächliche Grund
Ja es ist natürlich auch nice
dass man weniger Tiere schlachten muss und so
dann für mich, aber
der hauptsächliche Grund ist,
weil es gesünder ist.
Die hat mit dem Kram angefangen.
Und ich finde es gar nicht schlecht.
Teambuilding-Event. Ja, ich hatte von Montagabend
bis Mittwochmittag
ein Teambuilding-Event.
Wo wir wieder ganz viele
tolle Spiele gemacht haben.
Wir haben Ikea-Regale
zusammengebaut.
Und wie toll man das im Team schneller kann als einzelne Leute das können.
Ah, das sind halt so die typischen Spielchen.
Also so Teambuilding-Events haben immer so ein bisschen was von...
...bisschen Kindergarten, bisschen Klassenfahrt, bisschen...
...Sightseeing.
Aber ich fand's nicht schlecht.
War echt okay.
Hab ich auch viel schlimmere Teambuilding-Events gesehen.
Nee, danach wurde wieder abgebaut.
Es waren auch keine echten Ikea-Regale,
aber das hieß Ikea-Regal.
Das war so...
Mal gucken, ob ich das finde.
Team-Building.
Ikea-Regal.
Nö, finde ich jetzt nicht.
Das war kein richtiges Regal.
Das wurde nur so zusammengesteckt wie ein Regal.
Es gab eine Aufbauanleitung und da musstest du so die Dinger hier zusammenstecken.
Aber da kam kein richtiges Regal bei raus.
Guck mal, eine Tower of Power.
Oder sowas ähnliches.
WTF, was machen die da?
Es gibt so viel, unglaublich viele dumme Spiele, die man da macht
Stream-Team-Building-Event
Ich glaube, das findet mein Arbeitgeber nicht so geil
Musstet ihr wieder auseinanderbauen?
Ja
Warum muss das verboten...
Ganz ehrlich, das ist so ein Ding.
Ich habe mich damit jetzt nicht beschäftigt.
Aber warum muss das verboten werden?
Ich meine, ganz so dumm sind die Leute doch nicht.
Ja, wenn da steht...
Wenn da vegane Schnitzel steht.
Da weiß doch jeder, dass es kein Fleisch ist.
Weil sonst wäre es nicht vegan.
Warum brauchen wir da irgendeine Regelung dafür?
Ich meine, so braindead kannst du doch gar nicht sein, dass du das nicht checkst.
Dann ist es kein Schnitzel.
Dann müsste ja alles, was mit irgendwelchen Zusatzstoffen oder...
Guck mal, beispielsweise die Erdbeeren, ja?
Die Erdbeeren in Erdbeerjoghurts.
Da habe ich mal einen Beitrag drüber gesehen, dass das Erdbeerfleisch da drin gar kein Erdbeerfleisch ist,
sondern irgendwelche dinger die auf sägespänen wachsen dann dürfte es auch
nicht erdbeerjoghurt heißen verstehe ich nicht also man kann den leuten noch
manchmal zutrauen dass sie nicht komplett brain dead sind und verstehen
wenn da veganes schnitzel steht das ist halt kein schweinefleisch sein kann
Achtest du mittlerweile eher auf kleine Portionen?
Nö
Ich fresse immer noch viel zu viel
Wenn auch gesünder
Echt
Das fällt doch sofort auf
Weil es groß drauf steht
Vor allem, weil es viel teurer ist oftmals
Das ist ja auch sowas, veganes Zeug
Ne? Also ich hab
Letztens ein veganes Steak
Gefuttert, das ist irgendwelches Sojakram
Oder so, keine Ahnung
Das hat dank der Würzmischung gar nicht so schlecht
Geschmeckt, hatte nicht wirklich was von Steak
War aber teurer als
Echtes Fleisch, so
Also wirklich viel Geld
Sparen tut man damit nicht, das ist eher teurer
Aber trotzdem, ich ernähre mich da in letzter Zeit ganz gern etwas fleischärmer.
Weil es einfach nicht gesund ist, so viel Fleisch zu futtern.
Ich habe mir so eine Körperfett
Du meinst eine Waage
Keine Körperfett Wake
Körperfett Waage geholt
Das
Das kann meine Waage angeblich auch.
Ich hab so eine Xiaomi Mi Scale oder irgendwie so wie dieses Ding heißt.
Das kann meine Waage angeblich auch, aber ich trau der Sache nicht.
Ich benutze das nur für Gewicht.
Sind die nicht ungenau?
Wahrscheinlich.
Es gab doch auch mal so eine Waage.
Da hast du dann so einen Griff in die Hand genommen, noch zusätzlich.
Die sollen angeblich genauer sein, also sagen die in der Werbung.
Aber ich brauche das nicht, muss mein Körperfett nicht messen.
Ich weiß auch so, dass ich zu dick bin.
Trotz viel Gejogge.
Aber ich bin glücklicherweise nicht mehr so fett wie vor ein paar Jahren.
Da hatte ich 108,5, jetzt habe ich 86.
Ich habe wieder ein bisschen zugenommen.
okay jetzt habe ich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr als 86 weil ich beim team
building event so viel gefressen habe jetzt habe ich wahrscheinlich jetzt habe
ich wahrscheinlich 88 oder so weil team building event pippo fett
ja ich würde sagen wir gucken noch ein video das ding ist bloß das geht jetzt
es nicht mehr, weil in
16 Minuten
16 Minuten gibt es Essen.
Das ist ja
ganz ungewohnt heute. Ich weiß,
aber kann ich nichts
dagegen machen. Wenn es Essen gibt, muss ich ran.
da gibt es nichts.
Messen sie nicht nur den Widerstand?
Ja, irgendwie. Und dann errechnen sie daraus
den Körper fett. Wie genau
das ist, ich gucke kein
Video auf Pornhub.
Selbst wenn es Fire Ship ist.
Wer weiß, was da noch irgendwie eingeblendet
wird, selbst wenn ich es Fullscreen mache oder
sonst was. Das will ich im Stream
nicht eingehen, das Risiko.
Was es gibt?
Bolognese
mit ein bisschen Pilz drin,
aber veganem Hackfleisch.
Heute Nachmittag streamen.
Tja, was könnten wir denn streamen?
Ich muss auf jeden Fall nachher noch
47 Minuten meine Runde hier drehen.
Heute, Moment,
Chat, Chat, ich guck mal kurz,
ich guck mal kurz in meinen Trainingsplan,
was heute dran ist.
Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Ich muss mal kurz das Handy und die Uhr holen.
So.
Eine Runde Battlefield 6 streamen.
Ich habe Battlefield 6 nicht mal installiert.
Ich Depp habe es gekauft,
aber nie installiert.
Also, was ist denn heute dran?
Training, Workouts, Daily Suggestions.
So, was haben wir heute?
39 Minuten sind es nur, okay.
39 Minuten Grundlagenausdauer.
Und zwar bei einem Pace von 6,35.
Ja, gut.
Das werde ich dann nachher mal machen.
Morgen ist Rest angesagt.
Und am Dienstag ist 37 Minuten Threshold angesagt.
5.35.
Aber das wird anstrengend.
37 Minuten, 5.35, das wird anstrengend.
Das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Garmin-Coach, ja.
Nee, ich bin schlecht im Schnellfehler-Freitippen.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Es ist besser, als einfach nur so nach, wie es einem gerade ist, zu rennen.
Ja, sicherlich ist es besser, wenn du einen richtigen Trainingsplan hättest,
von irgendeinem Typ, der Ahnung davon hat.
Anstatt irgendwie den Garmin-generierten Trainingsplan.
Aber ganz ehrlich, es ist besser wie,
oh ja, heute isst Mismar danach, ich renne mal eine halbe Stunde.
Und mittlerweile habe ich ja...
Also ich hatte ja so eine Entzündung am Schienbein.
Richtig dicken Knubbel am Schienbein hat wehgetan.
Dann habe ich drei oder vier Wochen fast gar nichts gemacht.
Und dann habe ich das jetzt mal endlich richtig gemacht wieder.
Ich habe das langsam gesteigert.
Ich bin Rennen gegangen, zwei Tage Pause.
Rennen gegangen, zwei Tage Pause.
Rennen gegangen, ein Tag Pause.
Bisschen länger Rennen gegangen, Tag Pause.
So, und jetzt kann ich eigentlich schon wieder ganz normal die ganze Woche über joggen gehen.
Und ja, so alle paar Tage mal so einmal die Woche halt einen Rest-Day.
Ja, einmal die Woche ungefähr wird nichts gemacht.
Aber das ist halt ein ganz gut ausgewogener Plan, was dieses Garmin-Ding erstellt.
Da sind beispielsweise auch Tage drin, die sind zwar keine Rest-Days,
aber da sollst du nur ganz langsam 28 Minuten Recovery-Run machen und sowas.
Und das bringt tatsächlich was.
Also ich habe es jetzt schon öfters gemerkt, wenn man einen Tag einfach,
also wenn man sich richtig angestrengt hat, einen Tag danach einfach gar nichts macht,
ist es oftmals nicht so erholsam, wie wenn man den Tag danach wirklich langsam einfach mal 28 Minuten läuft.
Das regeneriert sich viel schneller, wenn man ein bisschen Bewegung hatte.
loch und ja sowas hatte ich wahrscheinlich auch knie habe ich überhaupt
kein problem ich habe ein paar guides auf youtube
geguckt wie man gescheit laufen soll so von wegen mittig auftreten die knie ein
bisschen höher machen als man sonst macht so ich glaube meine lauftechnik
Ist ganz okay.
Gib dir Garmin dann während des Trainings Tempoangaben vor.
Ja.
Ja, das ist zum Beispiel...
Warte mal.
Ja.
So sieht das dann aus.
So was kriegst du dann hier auf deinem Handy angezeigt.
Das bedeutet hier, du läufst dich...
Also ich meine, so schnell laufe ich nicht her.
Das ist dann hier, du läufst dich ein, dann machst du 2x5 Intervall oder so.
2, 3, 4, 6.
Also, das was da unten steht, stimmt irgendwie nicht so ganz.
Weil 3x8, das sind 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Das sind 2x6 Intervall-Dinger.
Na gut, so siehst du das dann.
Und wenn es soweit ist, zeigt dir die Garmin Uhr an, was jetzt drankommt.
Die sagt dir dann erstmal, jetzt Viertelstunde einlaufen, at 6.35.
Dann läufst du dich ein, wenn dann der erste Intervall drankommt oder ein bisschen längeren Dings,
sagt die Garmin Uhr, jetzt kommt, jetzt folgt, also in 10 Sekunden folgt ein Sprint,
30 Sekunden
oder 10 Sekunden oder eine Minute,
was auch immer, das und das und das.
Und dann jetzt 3 Minuten
Recovery dazwischen. Add so und so viel.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Ja.
Das ist wirklich nice
Also wirklich gute
Bilder gibt es dafür jetzt nicht
Aber im Prinzip war es das halt
Wie man es da oben gesehen hat
Bloß man kann es sich auch auf dem Handy angucken
Moment
Ich kann gleich was dazu sagen.
Wir haken mal die Garmin-Sache ab.
Du kannst keine 5 Minuten laufen.
dann läufst du wahrscheinlich zu schnell.
Probier mal wirklich, dass du das Gefühl hast, es ist langsam.
Ja, so dass du wirklich denkst, okay, das ist jetzt wirklich langsam.
Dann bist du wahrscheinlich immer noch ein bisschen schnell.
Dann packst du 5 Minuten, also 5 Minuten, wenn du nicht gerade 300 Kilo wiegst,
5 Minuten am Stück langsam kriegt wahrscheinlich jeder hin.
Und du wirst merken, also solltest du das wirklich öfters machen,
Du wirst merken, wie schnell das steigt.
Gerade am Anfang, die ersten paar Monate, geht das wirklich massive rauf.
Von 5 Minuten zu 30 Minuten geht es schneller, als du gucken kannst.
Muss man ständig auf die Uhr schauen oder kann man das mit Kopfhörern verbinden?
Kannst du beides machen.
Du kannst auf die Uhr gucken.
Was ich ganz nice finde.
Du kannst es aber auch mit Kopfhörern verbinden.
Also standardmäßig ist es so eingestellt, dass das dir ansagt, was jetzt drankommt.
Also so nach dem Motto, eine Minute so und so schnell.
Und nach jeweils einer Runde, eine Runde ist standardmäßig bei Garmin ein Kilometer, sagt es dir an, wie schnell du den Kilometer gelaufen bist.
Das sagt es dir entweder über den Handy-Lautsprecher an oder über Headset, was du im Handy gekoppelt hast.
Kopfhörer.
Ja, und wenn es dir immer noch zu schnell ist, dann kannst du auch laufen.
Also gehen.
10 kmh ist flott.
dann würde ich eher ein bisschen langsamer laufen
und länger laufen dafür
10 kmh ist relativ flott
das ist ungefähr so ein
so ungefähr ein
6er Pace würde ich sagen
bisschen schneller als ein 6er Pace
ähm
ja
was ist denn das für ein Pace
10 kmh.
Ja doch.
6 Minuten pro Kilometer.
6 Minuten pro Kilometer ist,
wenn man nicht geübt ist, ziemlich schnell.
Die Größe hat doch damit gar nicht so viel zu tun.
Guckt euch mal an.
Der...
Wie hieß der?
Marathon?
Cheepoge
oder irgendwie so. Wie hieß der Typ?
Cheepoge?
Irgendwie so. Alter, ich kann das nicht schreiben.
Ja, der da. Den da meine ich.
Der ist nur
Körpergröße.
Der ist nur 1,67.
Also mit Größe hat das nicht so viel zu tun.
10 kmh ist flott.
10 kmh ist ein 6er Pace
ein 6er Pace ist für ungeübte Leute sehr schnell
da würde ich lieber
langsamer laufen und dafür ein bisschen länger
aber besser ist
also wenn du wirklich ein bisschen üben möchtest
du kannst dir eine günstige Fitnessuhr
kaufen, dann ist das viel einfacher zu
tracken
5er Pace für 2,8 Kilometer
ist ziemlich gut
also wenn ich
also hier, meine Uhr sagt mir
zum Beispiel, ich soll
warte mal, wo war es
ich habe einen threshold run das ist quasi also mit dieser diese schwelle ist gemeint wo deine
muskeln gerade so viel laktat aufbauen wie du ab transportieren kannst also quasi wo deine
muskeln gerade so viel ermüden wie du regenerieren kannst so ungefähr könnte man das glaube ich sagen
und wenn ich 535 renne für 37 minuten ist das schon echt anstrengend
deswegen ist 5 pace ungeübt 2,8 kilometer nicht schlecht ziemlich gut
naja
so sieht's aus fitness fitness influenza max am start so wie hier ich habe ich
habe ja letztens habt ihr es gesehen ich habe mir letzten schon
warst du fahrradfahren ja war ich ich habe mich letztens ja hier schon eine
Minus 59 als Fitnessinfluencer auf Twitter
betätigt. Ich hab mein Fahrrad kaputt
gemacht.
Letztens,
letztens ist es auch schon wieder ein paar Wochen
her, ich hab's ja im Stream erzählt,
letztens hab ich mir gedacht, ey komm, richtig schönes
Wetter, jetzt geht es richtig los, auch mit
gutem Wetter und allem, jetzt geht's wieder Fahrradfahren.
Ich glaube, ich kann
da nicht wirklich viel dafür.
Da bin ich eine Runde, bin ich eine Runde
gefahren mit dem Fahrrad, ja, ordentlich zackig
und da geht's halt eine
Gravel-Strecke, bisschen
bergab. Ja, du bist da schon
so
40, 45 fährst du da
auf Schotter. Das heißt,
es schüttelt richtig durch. Ja,
schüttelt dich massive durch.
Und
da muss ich wohl,
das ist das Einzige, wie ich mir das erklären kann,
weil da lagen ein paar Baumstämme und so rum.
Und da muss ich wohl,
oder Baumstümpfe, Baumstämme,
da muss ich, ja, es geht halt ordentlich
bergrunter, ja. Also das ist wirklich
so ungefähr fühlt sich das an.
Das ist hart durchgeschüttelt.
Und
da bin ich wohl
mit meiner Schaltung hinten.
Also mit dem unten Teil
von der Schaltung.
Ja, also mit dem unteren Teil hier
mit diesem Ding hier.
Mit dem Käfig
muss ich wohl
gegen irgendwie so einen Baumstumpf,
Baumstamm,
was auch immer gekommen sein.
Weil das hat sich verbogen.
Und dann ist mir die Kette
vielleicht ist auch nur das Schaltauge verbogen,
wenn ich Glück hab.
Und da ist mir immer die Kette runtergesprungen.
Ich hab die dann wieder drauf gemacht
und hochgeschaltet, aber es hat alles nichts gebracht.
Es ist immer wieder runtergesprungen hinten.
Und dann hatte ich ein Problem.
Dann stand ich im Wald
mit meinen Schuhen an.
Das sind Schuhe, mit denen kannst du nicht gut laufen.
Das sind solche hier.
Schuhe mit Boa-Verschluss.
So was hier.
Nicht wirklich.
Also das sind welche mit ganz harten Sohlen.
Maria.
Enrad.
Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung.
Nur, dass ich Mountainbike-Klick-System habe.
Das sind hier unten ganz starre.
Also das sind keine normalen Schuhsohlen.
Das ist ganz hartes...
Keine Ahnung, Plastik wahrscheinlich.
Das ist ganz steif.
Du kannst da drin deinen Fuß nicht abrollen.
Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so, wie bei Laufschuhen mit Carbonplatte, dass das federt oder so.
Dass du das schön, zwar deinen Fuß nicht abrollen kannst, aber du schön federst und ein bisschen Energie...
Ne, das ist einfach nur brutal hart.
Und damit musste ich 6 Kilometer durch den Wald laufen und das Fahrrad schieben bis zur nächsten Straße.
Ja, fürs Rad, wenn ich einen platten Reifen hätte, beziehungsweise einen platten Schlauch eigentlich.
Da habe ich sogar einen Ersatzschlauch dabei.
Das könnte ich theoretisch fixen.
Aber das konnte ich unterwegs nicht fixen.
Und da musste ich sechs Kilometer durch den Wald laufen bis zur nächsten Straße
und mich da von einem Uber abholen lassen.
Das hat gesackt.
So, und jetzt müsste ich mir das Ganze halt mal angucken.
Vielleicht, das Schaltauge habe ich noch zwei Stück da,
habe ich das letzte Mal drei Stück bestellt.
Vielleicht muss ich auch die Schaltung, also unten dieses Schaltungsding austauschen.
Das kostet halt gleich 230 Euro, das Ding.
Das ist eine Di2-Schaltung, so eine Wireless-Schaltung.
Die Dinger sind teuer.
Gleich 230 Euro ausgeben für...
Ich hoffe, es ist nur das Schaltauge und es geht dann wieder alles.
Es ist halt ein bisschen kacke, dass das jetzt kaputt ist.
Ich bin jetzt die letzten Tage ein bisschen auf meinem Indoor-Trainer mal gefahren, so eine halbe Stunde oder so.
Aber ich sag euch ganz ehrlich, wenn es so warm ist
Und Indoor-Trainer
Ich mach zwar die Klimaanlage an, aber trotzdem ist das eklig
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ich kann ja nichts
Also komm
Hierfür kann ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, 50% was
Das kann immer passieren
Und für das erste Mal, dass mich da einer
Auf dem Fahrradweg über den Haufen gefahren hat
Da kann ich ja nun wirklich nichts dafür
Eindeutig User-Fehler, ja
Es ist ein Gravel-Bike, ja.
Aber es hat eine Mountainbike-Schaltung.
Wobei, es hat eine GRX-Schaltung.
GRX ist ja die Gravel-Gruppe da von Shimano.
Aber letztendlich ist es das gleiche Problem.
Du fährst halt auf unwegsamem Gelände
und kannst mal irgendwo dagegen schalten.
Ich hoffe, es ist wie gesagt nur das Schaltauge.
Dann kriege ich das recht easy gefixt.
Anwenderfehler, so wie beim Fiat Champ.
wichtig.
So.
Eine Sache habe ich gemerkt,
wenn wir jetzt gerade schon bei Sport machen sind,
was sehr
angenehm ist,
früher habe ich das immer so gemacht,
habe ich auf meinen Trainingsplan geguckt,
habe gesagt, aha, 45 Minuten
Grundlagen-Ausdauerrunde, 6,35,
let's go, habe ich mir
meine Rennklamotten angezogen, meine
Uhr und bin rausgegangen, hab die Uhr
angedrückt, bin losgelaufen. Und da hab ich
schon gemerkt, ey,
so den ersten
halben Kilometer, vielleicht manchmal auch den ersten
Kilometer, ist irgendwie
unangenehm und irgendwie
auch so komisch anstrengend und das muss
ich dann erst wieder einpendeln. Ich hab mich nicht großartig
aufgewärmt. Was ich manchmal gemacht hab, ist
ich bin ein bisschen gehüpft
im Flur oder so, aber das war's.
Was ich jetzt seit einer Weile mache, ist
ich werfe
Swift an.
Das ist so eine...
Kann ich euch nicht zeigen, weil ich hier nicht eingeloggt bin.
Das ist so eine
Fahrradfahr-App.
Ja, so sieht das aus.
So eine Fahrradfahr-App.
Und da fahre ich mich
auf meinem Indoor-Trainer 5 bis
15 Minuten, je nachdem
was heute für eine Runde angesagt ist.
5 bis 15 Minuten warm.
Und danach
ist das so ein
angenehmes, nices,
äh,
angenehmer, nicer Start
ins Laufen, das ist viel besser.
Das ist das Fahrradforser. Ja, nur, dass
es eine ziemlich miese Grafik hat.
Also die Grafik ist wirklich, die Grafik
sagt wirklich richtig krass, äh.
Also schön ist es nicht.
Aber das muss ja auch auf billig, billig
Smartphones laufen.
Ja, guckt euch das mal an. Also,
wie gesagt, schöne Grafik ist was anderes
jetzt.
Ja, Fortnite.
Fortnite-Grafik trifft es ganz gut.
Taugen die Dinger was?
Was meinst du?
Diese Indoor-Trainer?
Ja, finde ich schon.
Finde ich schon.
Also ich habe einen Wahoo
Kicker Core, glaube ich.
Den Einser noch.
Nicht den Zweier. So, und hier diesen Trainer habe ich.
Da kommt...
Genau, so sieht das dann aus
im Endeffekt. Du brauchst halt ein Fahrrad.
Du machst das...
Also das Fahrrad gehört nicht dabei, wohlgemerkt.
Das ist nur hier dieser Trainer.
Den Trainer und...
Also eine Matte würde ich auch auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Weil ansonsten schwitzt du halt
deinen Teppichboden voll oder wo immer du bist.
Das ist nicht so geil.
Und du brauchst halt ein Fahrrad.
Bei dem Fahrrad wird das hintere Rad rausgemacht.
Und es kommt halt auf...
Wird halt hier auf den Trainer aufgelegt.
Du behältst in der Regel die originale Gangschaltung bei.
Es fällt nicht easy um.
Das hier vorne brauchst du übrigens auch gar nicht.
Das hier vorne ist outdated, overrated.
Wieso fährst du nicht einfach draußen?
Weil ich im Winter nicht gerne Fahrrad fahre, weil mein Fahrrad gerade kaputt ist.
Übrigens, das ist ein geiles E-Mode.
Schade, dass man das nicht...
Das ist Mr. Bean E-Mode.
Ja, genau.
So sieht das aus.
Oh, es gibt Essen, Leute.
So, excellent.
Spiel wieder da.
Das musst du bei einem mehr oder weniger
Trainer gucken, wie viel das aushält.
Aber in der Regel ist es nicht
deine Beine.
Sind das eher deine Beine, die das begrenzen?
Übrigens, das Setup, was der hier hat, ist Premium.
Also normalerweise hast du nur das hier.
Es gibt aber auch ein...
Wahoo...
Wie heißt denn das Ding? Schaltung?
Ich hab vergessen, wie das Ding heißt.
Es gibt so einen...
Click heißt das, glaube ich.
Click?
Wie heißt das? Click?
Cock
Yep, Cock hieß das, genau
Swift Cock
Das, das, ähm, da kriegst du so
So einen Controller
Und, und eine Fake Gangschaltung
Die simuliert die Gangschaltung
Nur, was aber kein Problem ist
Weil
den Widerstand mit dem
Smart Trainer quasi
simulierst. Und du kannst
quasi dann virtuell schalten, ohne dass du eine echte
Schaltung brauchst. Macht es halt ein bisschen fehleranfälliger.
Habe ich nicht. Ich habe meine Originalgangschaltung
noch dran. Und was der hier hat, ist halt das
Premium Setup. Der hat noch einen Lüfter vorne.
Das ist ein Lüfter.
Der produziert Fahrtwind, je nachdem wie schnell
er fährt. Das ist
mega nice. Ich habe das
nicht. Ich habe das mal probiert mit einem Lüfter.
Mit so einem Heizlüfter einfach auf
kaltgestellt. Mittlerweile mache ich einfach die
Klimaanlage im Arbeitszimmer an.
Aber sowas will ich mir auch noch kaufen, wenn
ich endlich mal geschafft habe,
mein Arbeitszimmer aufzuräumen
und hier hinten
meine Fahrradecke bauen kann.
Ja, da habe ich jetzt ein Sofa stehen mit ganz
vielen Amazon-Kartons drauf und so. Das will ich alles
rausschmeißen und hinten in die Ecke dann das Fahrrad
stellen, unter anderem halt auch mit so einem Lüfter.
Hast du dafür ein Fahrrad
geschlachtet? Ja und nein.
Ich hatte vor,
ist mittlerweile wahrscheinlich schon drei Jahre
her oder so, hatte ich
einen Fahrradunfall.
Und
das Fahrrad ist laut Gutachter
ein Totalschaden.
Und das Fahrrad habe ich dann einfach
genommen und auf so einen Smart Trainer
gestellt. Weil
ob mir das auseinanderfällt,
auf dem Smart Trainer
Ist nicht so wild. Da kann ich nicht weit fallen.
Auf der Straße fahren wurde mir davon abgeraten.
Und die Versicherung hat eine Weile gedauert, aber hat es bezahlt.
Immer in Bruchteilen.
Also kann ich empfehlen. Ist nice.
Und gerade für Winter oder wenn das Fahrrad kaputt ist oder man nach der Arbeit nur mal schnell fahren will und sich nicht umziehen will, großartig, ist das top.
Die Sitze sehen immer so unbequem aus, macht man sich da nicht alles unten kaputt?
Also, du brauchst immer einen Sitz, der gut passt.
Aber wenn du einen Sitz hast, der gut passt, ist das für lange Strecken besser als diese super bequemen Sattel
Weil die super bequemen Sattel, die sind weich und da scheuerst du dich richtig wund über lange Strecken dran
Und auch wenn du irgendwelche Falten hast oder so, wackelst du da mit dem Arsch drauf rum auf diesen Sätteln
Und du scheuerst dich bei bequemen Sätteln über lange Strecken mehr auf als bei diesen harten Sätteln
Auf einem harten Sattel, da musst du dich dran gewöhnen, aber da sitzt du eher weniger auf deinem Fett, sondern du sitzt mehr auf deinen Sitzknochen und wackelst nicht so viel rum.
Ja, das ist gewöhnungsbedürftig und die ersten zwei, drei Wochen tut dir auch ein bisschen der Poppes weh, wenn du da drauf gefahren bist, aber danach geht's.
Ja, das reizt halt ein bisschen die Knochenhaut an Stellen, wo du sonst halt nicht, das nicht gewöhnt bist.
Aber nach zwei, drei Wochen gewöhnt sich da dein Hintern dran.
Und dann ist das besser als so ein bequemer Sattel.
Und, das darf man genau, und das darf man auch nicht vergessen,
in der Regel ziehst du ja da Bip-Shorts oder Bip-Hosen an.
und die haben
ein Polster.
Polster drin.
Guck, sowas, sowas hier in der Richtung
haben die dann da drin.
Da hast du quasi so eine Polsterung
drin, die ganz praktisch ist.
Die geht nämlich auch ein bisschen an den Seiten, das heißt,
du scheuerst dich nicht so sehr an den Beinen auf
und die haben auch so eine Form,
die packen dein Gemächt
Kocka.
Die packen dein Gemächt ganz gut ein
So dass ich das
Dass das nicht taub wird auf dem Sattel
Oder du das irgendwie dran scheuerst oder so
Also sie sind für genau sowas gemacht
Ja mich wundert es
Dass es das
Dass es die Maut nicht mehr gibt
Komisch ne
So, Leute.
Jetzt muss ich was futtern.
Bisschen kürzer.
Stunde kürzer als sonst.
Zu NixOS zu wechseln.
Nein.
Habe ich nicht überlegt.
Habe ich auch nicht vor.
Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wann ich wieder da bin.
Ich vermute mal morgen.
Tatsächlich.
Weil ich muss ja noch ein bisschen strieben.
Sodass ich noch ein bisschen Sellout machen kann.
Da müssen wir mal unser...
unser Niri-Setup weiterbauen
mit Noctur...
Wie ist das? Noctalia-Shell oder so?
Aber jetzt esse ich erstmal was.
Wir hören uns, Leute. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.